e
good morning it being 10:00 I'd like to
start the presentation for uh the
capital budget
hb25 let's lead off with the Department
of Corrections
works good morning for the record my
name is Helen Hanks I'm the commissioner
of the Department of Corrections and to
my left is Heidi ly our administrator of
logistics I'm going let her take the
lead on this
morning I'm going to um briefly go
through um the approved projects and
then um a couple of additional projects
that we are requesting the committee
consider on page two of the presentation
in front of you uh We've listed out the
governor's proposed capital budget items
um numbers one two and three and beside
that we've listed what the Department's
priority is on those um the governor's
proposed number one was for electronic
controls and Camera
installations that is the Department's
priority number two Governor's propos
number two is to replace the HVAC units
using R22 refrigerant that is the
agency's priority number three and the
governor's proposed number three is the
boiler Surge and diator tank
Replacements that is the Department's
priority number
one some additional projects we're
asking the committee to consider today
are um replace the body alarm and manown
system at the Northern New Hampshire
Correctional Facility additional funding
for steam lines and traps at the New
Hampshire state prison for men replacing
the fire alarm systems at the New
Hampshire state prison for men and the
transitional work center in North End
house and uh removing the underground
diesel storage tank and installing above
ground tanks at the New Hampshire state
prison for men and the uh total
additional consideration is 15.4
million so so to review the um already
approved items number one is the boiler
Surge and deat tank Replacements on page
three you can see the inside of one of
our old boilers our boilers are were
over 40 years old um we recently had two
replaced uh we retubed the third one but
unfortunately that failed U because the
boiler was just beyond um repair um so
that third boiler is no longer in
service at this time we are using using
a temporary portable boiler system for
the winter months because our um
facility does need the three boilers to
operate in the winter
season uh on page four um it tells you
that boiler one's no longer in service
um as I said we're using a leased
temporary boiler our surge tank is also
unrepairable has a leak in it um that we
can't determine where that is because of
the insulation um and the tank is over
40 years old um Department of
administrative Services was kind enough
to give that us a tank that they were
not using however it's un undersized for
the existing system so although it's
being used temporarily it's not a
permanent solution um and the average
life expectancy for boiler equipment is
about 30 years on the New Hampshire
Doc's equipment is well over that
expectancy at over four years
old our next priority is electronic
controls and Camera installations it's
the Hampshire state prison for men
um currently we're using analog style
cameras in um quite a few places we have
313 total cameras of those 252 are still
analog
cameras um the the technology on them is
outdated um the pictures are very hard
to see they're not clear um we've lost
ability to zoom in and out in some cases
um digital cameras would provide a
clearer high resolution um image more
maneuverability uh increased zoom
capabilities and they have additional
features such as facial recognition Line
crossing and object detection and they
would provide improved operational
transparency and PR compliance and would
help protect the state from legal
challenges as well as provide safety
staff priority number three is to
replace the HVAC units using R22
refrigerant uh the EPA banned production
of hydrofluoric chloro
hydrochlorofluorocarbons um used it
which is used in R22 um that ban took
place in 2020 so R22 refrigerant is no
longer manufactured or imported into the
US So currently there's a high demand um
for the product but a very limited
Supply which is depleting as each year
goes by and which is causing the price
to continue to rise for that currently
our 22 average is about $120 per pound
um the nor newer more environmentally
friendly refrigerants such as R 410A
averages about $60 per pound which is
half the cost um our existing um HVAC
systems that use the R22 refrigerant are
in poor condition and in need of
replacement due to age many of them
again over 40 years old original to the
buildings when they were
constructed um and replacing these hbac
systems would provide the state with
some Energy Efficiency um cost savings
state the agency's priority number four
and this is an additional project we're
asking the committee consider um the
Northern New Hampshire convectional
facility um to replace the body alarm
and manown system their existing Bosch
Security escort system was installed in
2000 the year the facility was opened um
the system utilizes approximately 110
personal transmitters which transmit a
signal to the prison's main control when
a distress alarm is activated by the
user Bosch no longer manufactures this
system or any components of this system
they issued an end of life notice on
April 1st
2022 and the doc was obtaining
replacement transmitters and system
parts from third-party retailers such as
eBay and Facebook Marketplace for a
period of time um but stock has now been
depleted we can't find more than a oneof
here or a one there um certainly not
what we need to maintain this system
um so we now that we can no longer see
Parts um as the transmitters break down
and can't be repaired they are offline
we don't have a replacement for
them the next project we're asking the
committee to consider is the additional
funding for steam lines and traps at the
New Hampshire state prison for men we
did recently complete a project that
replaced a significant number of uh feet
of steam line underground um in the
facility which helped considerably
considerably um with the leaking however
we do have one substantial leak um that
runs from our Boiler House to um inside
the facility and the that leak is
costing us about 16,000 to 18,500
gallons of water loss per day
unfortunately it's not something can be
repaired without excavation through the
building um this loss obviously
increases our water usage and our boiler
chemical treatment usage and add and in
turn adds cost to our operating budget
it also causes a reduction in the boiler
operational efficiency equivalent to
about 211 horsepower which is about
two-thirds of the boiler operational
capacity of our boilers so essentially
we have one boiler that's only operating
at about onethird capacity due to this
loss and this loss is also creating
strain on our brand new boilers which
are working working harder to compensate
for the loss of the condensate
return priority number six that we're
asking the committee to consider is to
replace the fire alarm systems at New
Hampshire state prison for men including
transitional work center and North End
house as you can see from the photos we
have quite a bit of
deterioration um the annual maintenance
costs on our fire alarm system and 2024
were approximately
$39,000 um we get frequent system faults
and Phantom alarm activations due to the
deteriorating wiring um and this is
causing the fire department to respond
to non-emergency several times a year um
there is one Loop that attaches to five
buildings underground and that is one of
the root causes and it's nearly
impossible to find the source of the
fault on that Loop um just because of
how long it is and how far it
goes um the system's been modified and
added to over the years much of the old
wiring was abandoned in place by
contractors so when new contractors come
in to make repairs they're dealing with
essentially spaghetti wires trying to
find the source of the problem
um which adds obviously to the labor
costs um and the time that they're
spending doing
that um and the fire alarm system is
required to comply with NFPA
7214 2.2.2 point2 um which states that
system deficiencies shall be corrected
um for over three years now these
deficiencies have been noted on the
annual inspection reports by the state
fire Marshall's office due to the above
issues with the system um we do have do
try to facilitate repairs as much as
possible but sometimes s it just comes
down to they they can't find where the
issue
is um priority number seven that the
agency is asking the committee can
consider is to remove our remaining one
undergrounds diesel storage tank and
install above ground tanks in that
location um the tank and Associate
piping and controls need substantial
repairs to comply with the New Hampshire
environmental reg regulations this tank
is oversized based on the agency's
annual use of diesel fuel which is
mostly used to operate our equipment and
emergency generators so we're seeking to
remove the tank um and replace it with
two 600 gallon above ground storage
tanks one as a primary used tank and one
purposes um on page 17 we go into a
little bit about the replacement for the
correctional facility so the original
$10 million that was passed by
government Council um we have we are
utilizing engineering firm drr group
who's been doing um some site evaluation
um they've done a complete evaluation of
the site up and back um test boring um
utilities exploration um and they've
done some programming meetings or almost
all the programming meetings to get a
sense of how the docc operates and what
our needs are and um they'll be
completing a detailed master plan
document for the over 300 acres of docc
land which is up behind the New
Hampshire correctional facility for
women so they've completed Wetlands D
delineation the traffic study Geotech
borings and test pits um environmental
site assessment and um a utility
assessments um they've had visioning
sessions as I said and we should be
receiving um a final proposal from them
in May of
2025 with their recommendations on where
to site the new
facility on the $40
million um this will be for fall
architectural engineering services for
all design phases this will be for
schematic design design development
construction documents bid support and
construction Administration for the new
facility so it'll be a comprehensive
complete design and as part of that
we'll have a better idea what the
estimated cost will be for a replacement
facility
on page 20 um the projects that we are
um looking to lapse are listed excuse me
excuse me just just just one second
please I'd like to I'd like to stop
right there we've been stopping before
we get to the C the laps extensions make
sure if we've got any questions on any
of this right now please go ahead and
ask them from any oh we have a number of
them representative
Boyd thank you Mr chairman Lisa thank
you very much for your presentation a I
appreciate a couple
questions there's a lot of the
expenditures proposed for Capital
Improvements and I think historically as
a committee we're well aware especially
as it relates to the Men's prison that I
think the word dire doesn't begin to sum
up the situation that's going on there
um not that I'm in a recycling mode but
as we move forward and as we begin the
process of building the new men's
present is it conceivable that some of
the Appropriations that we're
considering today or Capital
Improvements would find their way to the
new
facility possibly um so the if we were
to replace the air handlers um with the
new Air Handlers those could potentially
be moved they'd have to be certainly
sized for um the location that they were
going in um but what the committee needs
to keep in mind too is we do have to
keep the current facility in full
operation um so to move an air Handler
to the new facility before we're ready
to actually move people over um might be
difficult so I think for the majority of
projects that's um not going to be able
to be feasible um the only one would be
the underground storage tank that is
located actually at the warehouse
facility um so that would continue
forward with the construction of the new
men's facility and representative I
would add part of the camera uh project
I asked the same question with the hope
that we might be able to take that
technology and move it up um part of the
concern lack of commitment we can't make
is whether it technology is going to
shift so much in approximately 10 years
even what we do now would be obsolete by
the time we moved in but we were looking
for those opportunities and gains and
that's a fair consideration commissioner
I appreciate that follow up Mr chairman
follow up okay regarding the underground
diesel storage tank you're looking to
remove it what's the benefit of removing
it as opposed to filling it up with sand
or cement and capping It Off
that's a great question and we actually
haven't explored that option um we
worked with environmental services and
we had an outside agency come in and
look to see the Litany of issues that
existed with the tank um I can certainly
find out if that's an option for us um
but it is an underground tank and it is
piped into um the warehouse building so
somewhere along the way that would have
and sir I I asked the same question
ironically I appreciate your question
there is diesel in it now uh part of the
question U that arose when I said could
we do just that uh was is there a way to
recycle any of the diesel that's in
there is there rust and erosion that
makes it unusable so very appropriate
question thank you thank you Mr chairman
you're welcome uh further questions uh
representative Brown representative uh
Newman I'm going to save you last
because I suspect I know what your
question
is thank you Mr chairman I have a
similar questions to representative
voids on the diesel tank and I do have
some experience with that so I would
expect that you could abandon the tank
in place as representative Boyd
indicated but my concern is uh it's
still operating so have monitoring Wells
been put in place is there any failure
or any diesel that's escaped from the
tanks or the piping
not that we're aware of um so so the
tank is approximately 5,000 gallons um
I've worked with the agency for just
over three years and we haven't filled
it yet um we use approximately just
below 400 gallons a year of diesel um so
we've just been slowly kind of chipping
away of that until we can get it to the
under I believe it's 600 gallons it's
required to put it into temporary
closure um and that's kind of where
we're at at this point we're just kind
of trying to use up the diesel so that
we can put it into temporary closure and
I don't believe we have any monitoring
Wells at this point um because there are
methods of testing the tank to make sure
that there's not any failure if there's
no failure I would think that we'd be
able to continue using that um till you
remove the diesel you can also pump that
diesel out filter it and put it into the
new tanks if you do indeed want to uh
replace that so if you want to discuss
that further I'd be certainly be glad to
talk to you about that but I would be
concerned about putting new tanks
especially since the plan is they have
such low use and there's no failure or
no piping issue with with the tanks I
would think that Dees would be able to
monitor that and at least extend that
use and maybe reduce the capacity of the
tank to just have the emergency capacity
kept in that tank so that's my thought
and I I have another question Mr
chairman sir um um the uh the man down
system
um who who uses that how many is that
the the guards that use that system or
who uses that system no so that would be
for our Correctional line staff or
civilian staff in the facility and
visitors so when visitors come to tour
the facility or or anything like that
they're issued a a body alarm tag so
that's a safety issue for for those
people thank you very much I appreciate
that any further questions
representative
vone thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question so to follow up
on the body alarm so you've got 110 uh
units that are still that you have in
total
yes oh so 110 how many are in use
basically during the course of a day a
week a month or whatever so basically
I'm just looking for you know do you
have spares or are
you are you at the point where you're
saying we don't have any more for today
so nobody else can come in the the
facility it depends on the day I mean
certainly there some days is there going
to be more you know if we have a
visiting tour or some something like
that there might be more usage um we're
almost at the usage capacity so the 110
is approximately how how many are given
out on a daily
basis thank you representative
Newman thank you my question is on the
least
boilers you you amazed me I I thought it
was going to be kitchens I would have on
the kitchens you've always worried about
the kitchen thank you for reminding me
on the on the least boiler that you've
got right now is there like a
maintenance contract that comes with
that so you pay x amount of dollars and
they take full responsibility
for no
so the the fee to lease the boiler is
for the boiler itself so they brought it
delivered it and they connected it to
the connections that we had installed
our maintenance staff monitor and
submits weekly reports to the to the uh
vendor letting them know what treatment
was put in and the performance of the
boiler and at the end of the lease term
they will return disconnect it and take
it
away can you lease that continually
leasing it um we can um we don't
generally need it in the summer months
because we can operate on the two
boilers in the summer months when we
don't need heat the heat is what puts
the additional load on the boiler system
where we need the three
boilers okay could I I still have still
have a question about it so I I guess
looking forward to maybe 10 years out
when there is a new prison
if is it did you think at all about what
if you don't get money right now but
maybe it would be I hate to say least
forever but lease boilers until you get
to a new facility would that be
something I think it's a possibility um
the problem is that we have a a surge
tank that's under siiz so that still
needs to be replaced um we have a lot of
piping valving and other things that are
have
deteriorated um our PK heaters which are
part of that system two of the four of
them don't work anymore um so there's a
lot of parts of the system that still
need to be replaced even if we to use
the temporary boiler every every Winter
thank you and I will ask are the Amazing
Blue tarps still up in the intake area
and in the kitchen area
yes all right thank you you're you're
quite
welcome yes one one more question
representative Brown thanks Mr chairman
I just just to follow up on the diesel
tanks the 600 gallons that you would
propose for the backup tank of these two
tanks is that used for electric backup
for security for that facility or what
is that what are those use for it would
be if we needed emergency fuel delivery
for our generators in the event of you
know long-term outage um any kind of
problems in the market where fuel became
an issue obtaining fuel became an issue
we need to keep the facility running so
that's a general power backup yes system
thank
you let's proceed with the laps
um okay so the uh laps extensions that
we are requesting um are for uh the New
Hampshire state prison for men door
replacement um and um together with that
the New Hampshire state prison for men
door and ceiling repairs for the closed
custody unit which is um third from the
bottom of that section um those two
items are being bid together um those
are preparing for bid as we speak um we
did put them out to bid previously um
but unfortunately the bids came back
more than doubl the appropriation um so
we had to descope the project a little
bit and it was going out for bid um the
kitchen renovation project that is also
being prepared for bid at this time um
we're looking at um bringing in a mobile
or modular kitchen unit um our
engineering firm has completed about 95%
of the site um design for that um once
we know what we can get for a mobile or
modular unit they'll be able to complete
site design um and so we would like to
keep that project moving forward um the
next one is the New Hampshire state
prison for men roof replacement project
that is in construction currently um We
have replaced the R&D and boilerhouse
roofs um the plaza deck replacement
which is part of that project because
that is the roof over our kitchen and
bakery area um that is in construction
right
now um rebuilding the sewer line and
grinder that project is in design right
now with um anticipating to go out to
bid soon on that um the roof replacement
project for the Handcock Industries
roofs that is in construction Handcock
roof has been completed the industries
roofs will be be um moving forward in
another week or
two um the door and ceiling um repair
and placements for closed custody we
already discussed the perimeter security
and fence detection
systems um that is at ncf or Northern
cral facility that is in construction
currently um they're actually getting
started uh getting ready to mobilize
right now um and the radio system
upgrade that is also in construction the
radio have been received and they are
being programmed
currently um some laps extensions that
we had uh previously requested but no
longer need is for the boiler
Replacements um that project has had
ended a little quicker than we
anticipated it was um so we should be um
all all set to lapse that um the door if
I could just interject uh that's number
65 in house build 25 okay um the door
control upgrade at um Northern Hampshire
ctional facility again we were having
some programming issues with that so we
were initi initially going to extend it
um but they've since resolved those so
we are um okay to lapse those that's
number
66 and the last item um that we no
longer need a lapse extension on is the
construction um Training Center building
or for um sorry construction and
Training Center for Building Trades at
New Hampshire Correctional facility for
64 so the on the lapse extension
requests on page 21 um first is the door
Replacements this was for a replacement
of shoe perimeter doors yard wall doors
and fence doors um and as I said the
first round of bids came at more than
came in at more than double the
allocated funding so we descoped the
project it's currently being prepared
for rebid we're estimating a start of
construction of this fall with a
completion in the spring of next
year kitchen renovation project um
includes the remodel of dining hall
three space into Bakery and special
diets prep area this is a dining hall
that we do not use currently except for
staging um purchase and installation of
the mobile and modular kit or modular
kitchen modifications to the existing
space to include new doorways and
relocation of the control room and
replacement of various kitchen equipment
the site design is nearly complete and
will be finalized once the modular
mobile kitchen bid award is awarded and
we're current currently preparing bid
documents for the mob mobile modular
kitchen we're estimating a start of
construction in summer of 2025 for the
bakery and special diet space uh fall of
2025 for the site work for the mobile
kitchen and spring of 2026 for delivery
and installation of the mobile kitchen
with a a total um project completion
2026 on page 23 um the roof Replacements
various roofs project at New Hampshire
state prison for men this was for
replacement of the spew CCU rtu roof the
boiler house roof the R&D roof and the
repair of the plaza deck above the
kitchen and bakery the replacement of
the spew CCU rtu roof was completed in
November 2022 due to due to stor storm
damage the boiler house and R&D roof
Replacements are nearly complete there's
just some um lightning protection they
need to finish up um so those should be
completed this month and then the plaza
deck above the kitchen and bakery area
is in construction with an estimated
2025 the rebuild sewer line and grinder
project this is to relocate the sewer
line and grinder station from Maguire
Street to the New Hampshire State Prison
from men parking lot Island um it would
be replacement replacing the grinder and
add addition of augur equipment the
project includes a small building to
house the grinder and augur and we're
currently finalizing design on that
estimating for that to go out to bid
this spring with start of construction
2026 on page 25 the Hancock and
industries buildings roof replacement as
I said the Handcock roof replacement is
nearly complete again also lightning
protection just needs to be finished on
that so that should be complete this
month uh the estimated start a
construction on the industries roof um
is also looking like it will be this
month and the estimated completion will
2025 the CCU door and ceiling
replacement and repair this is
replacement of the CCU exterior tiar
doors and repairs to the ceiling in spew
the first first round of bids came in at
more than double the allocated funding
so again the project was descoped and is
currently being prepared for rebid with
an estimated start a construction in
Fall 2025 and an estimated completion in
Spring
2026 the next is the Northern New
Hampshire Correctional Facility P per
perimeter security and fence detection
systems this is to upgrade the perimeter
detection system and replace some catch
Bas basins and drainage um improvements
in the courtyard to protect the fence
line Integrity um they should be
mobilizing next month for this project
with an estimated completion in summer
year next is the radio system upgrades
which is agency wide this is for
replacement of portable mobile and base
station radios and repeaters throughout
the agency we're working with the
Department of Safety as required by law
the equipment has been ordered and
received um and is currently being
programmed in the estimated
replacement will be this spring with an
summer and on page 29 uh that lists the
projects that we are elapsing balances
on um the estimated lapse amounts are in
the far right column um that would be
replacement of the electrical
services for a Men's prison theair um
sorry perimeter security and fence
detection systems at the Men's prison
the boiler Replacements at the Men's
prison Heating and Cooling coil
replacements for the North and South
wings of the administration building at
the Men's prison replacement of steam
lines and traps at the Men's prison uh
door Replacements at the Men's prison
this was the first phase of the door
replacement project and then the second
phase of the door replacement project at
the Men's
prison um and the body alarm man down
system at the Men's prison the northern
Hampshire Correctional Facility roof
replacement project the door controller
upgrade at Northern New Hampshire
Correctional
Facility the women's uh facility
construction training center for
Building Trades and at the transition
replacement so questions representative
Jack uh thank you stunningly uh
everything cross checks with what I have
uh and the three it items that we need
to change are numbers 64
65 and
66 uh in House Bill 25 should be lapsed
so we'll delete
those and if I'm reading that correctly
you are are lapsing a balance of
$550,500
yes representative Boyd thank you Mr
chairman going to and thank you for
taking my questions today I appreciate
it regarding the uh the door and ceiling
replacement and repair having to put it
out a bit is is it your experience that
materials are costing more than what was
originally budgeted yes and um due to
the nature of the prison environment um
we had multiple mobilizations in the
original bid which added to the cost um
so we had to come up with a creative way
to reduce the number of
mobilizations so that it would bring the
cost down in in the second round bids
okay follow up Mr chair follow up um I
noticed on the list of extensions the
sewer sewer line is in design how is
that going because I I we heard the
comments from last year so I'm just
hearing how it's going yeah um it's
actually going very well the city is um
pleased with our design the city
engineer um we're just looking at some
final detail things at the moment like
you know where fans are going to be
located and doors and things like that
on the building itself um we did there
was some design difficulties because
this the height of the equipment is so
tall um but we're at a good place and
we're we should be bidding that out
probably in the next month wonderful
good to hear thank you very much thank
you Mr CH you're welcome any further
questions representative
Newman yes thank you on the modular
kitchen is this the first time you've
gone to a modular
kitchen and and if I could
continue is your existing kitchen going
to be shut down and everything will most
of it so the primary part of the
existing kitchen and bakery area will be
shut down some office space will still
be used um and a storage room that's at
the very front of the building will
still be
used okay and last one one followup yes
it seems as though
maybe the first time I was there um is
is the health department behind going to
a modular kitchen or it's just that it's
just not feasible anymore to try them
yeah the difficulty becomes keeping the
kitchen operational while you've got
part of it shut down for um repairs it's
not sustainable given the number of
meals we're serving in a day um so we
just we couldn't pursue that so you'll
go to aular Kitchen from here on yes
okay yeah thank you you're welcome just
for clarification you were visiting
there you you weren't that's correct
okay we were visiting yeah just you just
casually said you know the last time I
was there you know that's why you're you
sounded like you were working in that
kitchen for a while so representative
Edgar uh thank you Mr chair and thanks
for taking my
question it has to do with the uh
training session uh session or Center um
it's listed here on page 20 as being in
design
um has that been
completely eliminated now at this
point so thank you for that
representative we have um lived that
project and attempted to deliver on that
project for some time as you know um I
think at this point we recognize
that maybe one would say a failure to
launch uh but we want to try some
adjustments inside the building before
we ask the state for additional dollars
and feel it's a better return to the
general fund while we navigate an
interior space using some uh
modifications to filter out sawdust and
other things and test that first uh
because when we first went out to bid
the 300,000 I would have had to come
back and ask you for almost a million
dollars as a legislature to fund an
actual separate building we tried to
change the scope of the building and
location of the building that still
wasn't within the 300 plus thousand that
was around 600
$800,000 um and navigating all of the
things we've navigated Co and so on and
the arpa projects uh we just think this
is the responsible decision to make at
this point uh thank you thank you Mr
chair you any further questions yes
representative rockmore thank you Mr
chairman thank you um my question is is
is it a pipe dream to imagine that
perhaps someday the kitchen that's being
decommissioned could someday be reborn
as a site for maybe some vocational
training some in the food Food Services
industry especially if perhaps license
plate manufacturing disappears from the
prisons I think the even the modular
kitchen as proposed would be appropriate
for us to continue a culinary arts
program so at the New Hampshire state
prison for men and at the New Hampshire
correctional facility for women there
are two culinary arts programs through
our vocational program and those
continue on uh despite the physical
limitations in the current space so
we'll continue to navigate that
thank you seeing no further questions
thank you very much for your
you
e
good morning moving on to Department of
works good morning uh for the record um
Bob Scott commissioner with the
Department of Environmental Services and
with me is Su Susan Carlson our chief
operating officer uh we have key staff
in the back as well so hopefully we'll
be able to answer any questions that you
have uh if it pleases the chair I'll
I'll I'll go through our uh slides uh
that we have proceed so thank you
so uh on slide two you'll see our our
summ of summary of our requests uh
effectively uh we're just just under $50
million and ask however I'll point out
and we'll go in detail in following
slides that uh just just shy of 20
million of that is for our wabaki River
Basin project which is bonded separately
and not part of the The General fund so
um so uh holistically what you'll see is
we as the agency uh we own and operate
uh and and maintain dams throughout the
state there are
263 or so uh state-owned dams um we also
as I mentioned we have a Wastewater Tuma
facility in Franklin and the collection
systems around that which uh serves 10
communities and then uh we'll go in a
little bit more detail uh we also
manage the the federal appropriation and
the repayment funds for the state
revolving loan funds so the these have
to do with
um uh drinking water and wastewater uh
projects typically as as passrs to the
communities and then finally we'll talk
about uh not in order but uh a super fun
match uh for for uh for those entities
or those uh sites that don't have a uh
known responsible party uh the state
ends up taking uh some some share of the
the responsibility for the care and
maintenance of those sites so moving to
slide
three uh I'll talk about dams a little
bit uh I will say uh this is part of a
larger uh concern concern that we have
uh there was a bill uh in the house uh
to start that followed a study committee
that was done last year to look at
funding for dams uh our request this
year is $10.8 million to to do Dam
repairs and Associated work uh the
typical going back over the decades the
again the monies generally come from the
the the capital budget for for Dam
repairs uh looking at our high Hazard
dams uh we rank uh the work with we do
but currently we're on a schedule of
rehabbing a dam uh every 100 years
uh which we don't find my my view is not
really sustainable if you will the
average age of our dams State own dams
is about a 100 years old also so at some
point uh we have an ongoing discussion
we'd like to kind of get a a different
source of funding a more sustainable
funded uh way of maintaining dams uh
kind of a more of a user fee uh system
is what we're we'd like to to have some
discussions with the legislature about
so moving beyond that issue what you see
in front of you is a list of uh 10
projects that we'd be doing with this
$10.8 million uh three of them are for
the Lakeport Dam uh which controls like
w w go basaki two of the projects are
for the Murphy Dam in Pittsburgh which
controls the head waters to the
Connecticut River um then we have um
some some uh two slope machines we're
again we're responsible for uh the
maintenance of the the grounds uh and to
make sure there's not improper erosion
around the the flood control dams uh
backup generators at at the facility in
silk Farm which is where we do the
maintenance and we deploy from should
there be an event and then uh we're
we're constantly upgrading and and
looking at our uh industrial control
controls or skater systems um in this
case we've uh we're looking at BO Lake
and straford Webster Lake in Franklin
little sunap Dam in New London
and the union Meadows Dam in Wakefield
New Hampshire uh is the work that's
slated on that end so and it so the last
thing I will
mention one of the questions the
committee the chair had sent to us is
what things had you asked for that are
not in
here were're were're it's workable for
us so we're not asking to be put in but
our original request had uh another $10
million for the four dams at pucky way
State Park uh our interest in that is at
least two of them need work sooner than
later and we're interested in lowering
that all at one time not doing four
different events where we take the the
Lake Puckaway and the state park out of
commission for for a year each time so
we're trying to coordinate that so that
was originally on our request we're not
asking for it back but I want to give
you an idea of the type of things in the
need for for dams as we move
forward so moving to to slide four which
is labeled clean water and drinking
water srf match that's the state
revolving Loan Fund I referred to uh as
you can see the state provides a 20%
match for both our drinking water uh
funds and our clean water again clean
water is is code for storm water and
wastewater uh usually it's wastewater
treatment um so the the the big issue
here is under the um
the infrastructure act uh we've received
a lot of extra money which is funneled
federal money which is funneled through
the state revolving Loan Fund uh given
that we have to do a match for for much
of that this is what the increase that
you're seeing here U and again this is
for a combination of loan and full loans
or loans with loan forgiveness uh for
for the federal federal
money and again chair Mr chair anytime
anybody wants to question is f fine with
us obviously so moving to uh Slide Five
I'll I'll pass off uh to Susan Carlson
here but we have a little bit more
detail in the state revolving Loan Fund
match good morning for the record Susan
Carlson with the on this slide what I
tried to do is provide you with a little
more information about how the srf
program the grant program works we
receive a grant as the commissioner said
we receive grants from EPA for both
clean water and drinking water um we
have a required 20% match on those
grants um in addition for the last five
years we've been receiving supplemental
Awards through the bill program also for
the last three of those five years we've
been required to provide a 20% match for
that so if you look at that if you look
at the chart for federal fiscal year 26
for both the clean water and drinking
water combined we're anticipating a
$22.1 million base Awards we're
receiving 47.5 in supplemental Awards um
total Awards adding up to 169 change
match requirement is 13.9 million we
have approximately a little over a
million dollars of match on hand so the
needed match for the federal fiscal year
26 Awards is 12.9 million in change and
if you notice when we get to 27 our base
Awards go up by approximately 4 million
again this is an estimate on our part um
the supplement awards are now completed
um through the bill program so our match
requirement drops down to 5.3 million in
change and those two combin add up to
the 18.3 that we are requesting it
should be noted that EPA will not give
us these Awards unless we have our match
in hand and in hand means an
appropriation so that's why you're we're
asking for these Awards now
M thank you so moving to slide six uh I
mentioned earlier super fund State match
so again this is
for uh sites that have no identified
responsible party uh in this particular
case we we're additional work is needed
for a site that was formerly at the New
Hampshire plating company uh again it's
a super fund site uh the remedy that was
original originally put in place is
found out not now not to be sufficient
there's additional contaminants that
have been uh causing causing the issue
and this is our po portion of that uh
paying for that that um that remedy at
the site uh if there's questions on this
too again we have our Waste Management
director Mike whimet here uh who could
go into details if you
need and then uh finally on slide seven
I mentioned our Waki River Basin project
so uh we
are in an interesting position as an
agency and as a state we actually own
and operate a wastewater treatment
facility uh in Franklin and in the in
the collection systems that go with that
uh it's an odd odd situation in my
opinion because we are also the
regulator of that so we we regulate
ourselves which is unique so um but they
do a really good job however uh much
much indicative of all these systems
throughout the state and the country
much of the uh infrastructure is aging
uh this the funds that wabaki River
Basin is 100% funded out of the 10
member communities so there's not a
general funded fund um infusion of money
or that type of thing but since it's a
state-owned facility again it goes for
the whole state system gets into the
budget and goes before you uh and again
uh su su Carl here can correct me if I'm
wrong but the the key here too is
there's a lot of needed needed work to
be done it's scheduled uh but again this
is bonded separately
not as the the main core of what you're
looking at so this is this is uh goes on
100% to those those member communities
and they and they repay the funds U as
they move forward so with that uh we're
certainly happy to answer any questions
that's a you know high level of our re
quests uh we do have uh the uh our laps
uh we have another handout here which
discusses our our
lapses uh and we can certainly discuss
those also so I again I wanted to be
know where the you know Mr chair
whatever You' like we're here at your
disposal thank you any questions for the
Department yes representative
BR I always have questions thank you Mr
chairman so on the dam repairs and
reconstruction couple of general
questions are these safety related
issues on on all these damps or just a
service
or operating to some extent they're all
safety re issues right so we do have we
we typically because again I mentioned
with the funding we get we're on a
100-year schedule so we we by by the
very nature of that we rack and stack
according to need uh and prior
prioritize High Hazard dams so we is we
have like 64 High Hazard dams whereby
which if the dam were to fail it
endangers life from property um so so
ultimately yes uh there there are again
263 state-owned dams there's another
2600 uh other dams in the state
also thank you Mr chairman so on these
dams you mentioned that you have four
projects at the PUO State Park I look
here at the uh summary sheet that you
have you have three project that look at
like they're at Lakeport and two
projects that are at at Murphy Dam corre
so were these projects that also had to
be coordinated and is this list in prior
to order as far as safety uh order or
how is this ordered I I'll have to defer
to cor Corey Clark he's the head of our
our dam Bureau uh but yes we try to
coordinate obviously lower most of these
repairs some of these repairs typically
involve lowering the level obviously lak
Port Dam uh we we would not like to
lower the level of uh Lake basaki by 12
ft which would be required if if we had
to take those those Gates out so so it
really depends again Corey I think does
a fine job uh of trying to navigate
there are times we we just don't have a
choice uh of mum's pond in barington is
a great example the the the pond there
the the dam there is being undercut
considerably so the dam needs to be
replaced there's just no ends a bus
about it I will I will and this is
generally at least since I've been
commissioner there's always been a
footnote on the budget for this that it
gives us the authority to kind of rack
and stack so for instance you you
approve this and we say thank you and we
move forward and then we find in our
inspections either there's a swirling
hole in front of a dam we prioritize
that and and we will use those funds so
so the ranking to the extent there is
which is what Cory's about to ask uh
answer uh it depends on the situation so
we we constantly evaluate and put the
money where it's most needed if that
makes sense so Cory can you sure for the
record Cory Clark chief engineer at the
dam Bureau nire Department of
Environmental Services so just to
elaborate a little bit more certainly um
we try to prioritize the best we can
it's a snapshot in time knowing the the
issues that we have uh one of the one of
the challenges that we have is as
commissioner mentioned we have 64 High
Hazard dams in the state now quite quite
often you a low Hazard Dam that all of a
sudden has immediate issues in which we
have to lower the empowerment therefore
you're you're sometimes playing you know
you're juggling the the line you know
you're trying to hit those High Hazard
ones because if they were to fail
there'd be probable loss of life but
sometimes an issue at a lwh hazard Dam
maybe the economic loss of that
empowerment is is uh is quite great
therefore we kind of bring that one up
the list and certainly as the
commissioner said when we dive into
these things we learn more and more one
thing um that I'll just mention is that
we were able to uh leverage about $30
million in arpa funds and we're
continuing to use that money towards the
repair and reconstruction of state owned
dams however as part of that we we did a
lot of studies with that money as well
which led to a lot of um unknowns
becoming knowns issues that we have at
various High Hazard sites um Pak Lakes
being one of those so one of the issues
that we found out with the four P Lakes
is that the the ultimate reconstruction
cost might be in excess of $10 million
so one of the things might be is further
down the line when we have better
construction estimates bring that back
forward to actually uh seek the repair
of those sites so um hope that answers
the question and certainly anything
else any further
questions representative jurus thank you
Mr chairman and your skater system how
old is the skater system and um are you
is there any thought to going to
yeah the ska system really came online I
would say probably about uh 10 20 years
ago as we we slowly started automating
some of these sites some of the the
first two sites that we automated was
Milton 3 ponds on the Salmon Falls River
and masoma Lake um about 20 years ago
since that time we've been slowly trying
to implement um more and more sites not
only being automated but more and more
data being collected at the sites as the
commissioner mentioned there's several
sites that we're trying to bring online
um for for data and what that really
helps us is our flood forecasting uh a
lot of times we by knowing what's coming
into a particular impoundment we then
therefore know what we need to do at the
dam prior to seeing the lake come up as
far as you know implementing newer and
newer Technologies that's something
we're always looking to do and certainly
trying to bring things up to uh current
standards as we as we move it move
forward but unfortunately it's kind of a
the age of the infrastructure is is is
anywhere from 20 years old to to current
so um we're slowly trying to bring
things up as we're replacing them and if
I could so the the the skat systems
we're talking about our plcs they they
oh okay yes and we do work uh fairly
closely with the DHS CA s security
infrastructure Security Agency they have
a really good representative here in the
state that works closely with us to make
sure that we're paying attention to
cyber security issues also because it's
great to automate but we'd like not to
introduce more vulnerabilities into the
dams as well
thank you just a quick follow up if I
could thank you Mr chairman uh so you're
monitoring and you're getting you're
getting these alarms any alarms in real
time is there also any video that you're
that you're pumping back to your your
office or your control site so we we are
getting the alarms real time we get
notified um when um you know anything
from a door to the gate house gets
opened to um high water alarms we have
alarms and monitoring walls at these
sites um we have brought in um camera
technology to several of these sites we
haven't gone to a full recording system
just because a lot of times these sites
are very public in and you know
notifying the public that they're being
recorded we haven't we haven't made it
to that that phase yet but the reason
one of the biggest reasons we have the
the cameras out there is if we're going
to do an operation we can see is there a
fisherman standing in the middle of the
stream Downstream fly fishing we're not
all sudden inadvertently dumping water
on him so that's that's the biggest
reason for the cameras out there but
we're kind of in continuing talks um in
house as to you know do we want to take
this a step further further and really
start implementing security procedures
with those cameras as well you got it
thank you representative Brown so thank
you Mr chairman just so I make sure I
understand this process with the w
River Basin program there's 10 10 Towns
that use the system the state operates
the system but all the cost associated
with are char back to the 10 Towns is
that correct yes so uh we there's a um
what's the word I want there's a uh a
board Advisory board made up of the
towns so as as the budgets work through
they agree to it and they start to
program in to their rates to be able to
pay for it thank
you seeing no further questions let's
move on to
the capital budget laps
extensions I'm going to pass on to uh
Sue Carlson on that so you do have a
handout uh that goes through goes
through that so she's uh a good asset
for us to talk to how's that uh I'm
gonna ask representative Jack did did
you have any particular questions on
this or not or do you want to go through
it line by line let me just start by
saying uh there's a slight discrepancy
with Hospital 25 what they have is
number 78 is number 80 what they have is
79 is number 81 what they have is 80 is
number 78 and what they have is 81 is
number
79 my
apologies I can only being one-handed
right now my typing isn't that
good
um yes good morning um as you can see
what I have done with this laps
extension memo is I have group the
extensions by the
topic um in the first two sections that
we are asking for laps extensions deal
with our hazardous waste match we have
two Appropriations that we are looking
to extend um the hazards waste matches
for the super fund programs this money
we are required by federal law to match
for 10% we do not control when this
money is being spent um we periodically
will get a statement from EPA saying
here is your bill for your next 10% we
pay the bill it is on their timetable um
um that they spend the funds on and we
um but we are mandated to keep this
appropriation here while um they're
getting to work on the new programs as
the commissioner said EPA is coming in
to do a what we understand to be an fair
amount of work on new what was the New
Hampshire plating former site so we're
hopeful that some of this match will be
used up in the next few
years the next section is um the LPS
extensions for the drink drinking water
srf program
um the way the program works is we are
required to provide our match upfront
but it often takes um with these federal
grants it takes us three to four years
to spend these funds down so when we
receive the
match um then we wait and then we
receive the Federal Grant and then it
takes us between three and four years to
spend that money down currently we're
spending on the 20 2 and 23 drinking
water funds we anticipate starting to
get through those um this fiscal year we
have been a little slow in spending the
match because we have had such a big
influx of arpa funds the last few years
and so our entire Focus has been on
getting the Opera funds out the door um
because essentially that's 100% Grant
and not alone to the communities um
obviously the drinking water and the um
clean water are loan programs
everybody likes free
money Y and if I could interject so also
for those aren't who may not be familiar
with the state revolving Loan Fund so we
we don't the state just doesn't issue a
check and say have a nice day go do good
things uh drinking water or Wastewater
system uh this is the monies are
dispersed as the the system does its
does its work and we verify both the
engineering uh is in accordance with
what what was agreed to and uh in these
type of funds there's a lot of federal
Cross Cutters Davis bacon or by American
Steel Etc so there's a lot of double
checking so so these projects especially
when we get to the Clean Water projects
take multiple years to to to go between
design and completion and we're again we
don't write a big check up front this is
reimbursement as it as it happens so so
it's not actually out of the ordinary
that it takes multiple years to actually
move the the finally move the money uh
to these uh systems
so um on the next page are the two
sections related to clean water just
like drinking water revolving Loan
program the Clean Water program also has
the match and actually where we takes
between two and four years for drinking
water loans it's taking between three
and five years to fully disperse um the
clean water clean water loans
on the top of Page Three are the
sections um the extensions for the three
Dam repair and reconstruction um
Appropriations that we
have those approximately um of the $4
million that we had appropriated in 19
um we um are asking to pull the last
$61,000 forward um that is our old that
is the oldest um appropriation for Dam
repairs and reconstruction then the 21
and the 23 money um we are in the middle
of working I will say a lot of the 21
money we are using in concert were the
arpa
funds um the 23 money which was a
$750,000
appropriation um most of that money is
going to be going to the Israel River
ice control structure removal um we've
been a little slow in getting that off
because um as Cory said we had over $30
million in Opera funds and we've been
concentrating on the OPA
funds section um for the construction
facility um we have spent nearly um all
of that we have a small amount of money
left on that one excuse me my voice is
going um and we looking just continue
that so that we can finish spending the
balance of the funds um through the
summer of
25 um the oap Lake Dam um for that one
we have um most of that remaining funds
is um currently encumbered under um
engineering contracts and we have
anticipated final repairs of $43,000
left we hope to get through this summer
and
fall on page
P um four is the Suncook River um what
is left is the $14,000 appropriation
that is in cupboard um that we are using
um with a con Construction contract with
f Marl to um do any La um emergency
repairs as a result of any spring
flooding that causes additional damage
and so that contract goes out through 28
so we're going to be spending that
14,000 through the end of
28 um the next three sections deal with
it
upgrades
um Das and doit have contracted with
Windsor solutions to provide um DS with
a new comprehensive e- permitting
management system this will get nearly
all of our permits online um and get us
off our Legacy
databases we have um currently more than
half of this money under current
contract and we anticipate getting the
balance of it under contract in the next
months on page five are the um wiip
basaki River base
improvements um these I will admit are
as our oldest
Appropriations um we are currently as
the commissioner said we have requested
$19.7 million in the current budget and
um we are using that plus all of these
funds that we have carried forward um to
do a major list of upgrades to the Winn
basaki Basin um there's a lot of work
that needs to be done on this nearly 50y
old system and um we are working very
hard to upgrade the Franklin facility
the pumps the sewer
system um
page on page six is our Coastal flood
modeling um these funds are nearly are
all fully under
encumbrance um the vendor has had a few
issues getting equipment in the door and
um they had a failure with one of their
data sets so this money is filling
cumbered but we expect it to be fully
spent sometime this
summer and then the last section is on
the groundwater to monitoring this is
for upgrading our monitoring welds um so
that we can understand in drought
situations where we stand we have spent
approximately half those funds um we are
we are in the process of putting out a
contract for the balance of these funds
to work on um upgrading the rest of our
new monitoring Wells throughout the
state and on the last page on page eight
I had um two Corrections AGB
25 um we wanted to delete a section on
permitting um which is the laps
extension there was about $4,000 left we
fully expect to spend those funds of
this year so we do not need a laps
extension and then um there is a small
error in the Waki appropriation for
2627 there is a reference to the
replacement fund and RSA
48551 the it should not be the
replacement fund and it should the
51 any question any questions
representative Jack yeah so that that
last correction that was mentioned is on
page two line
two and then uh we'll delete Number 96
at their request everything else cross
checks once
again we have any further questions for
DS seeing none thank you very much for
your
presentation
um we have the adant here does anybody
want to take a little five minute break
or not or should we just
well that's correct
all right moving forward to the
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services for the capital budget
welcome General thanks sir for the
record Mr chair and committee members
I'm Major General David mtis the agent
general for the New Hampshire National
Guard commissioner uh Department of
military Affairs and veteran services
and with me here today is Judy Chen our
Chief Financial Officer so i' like to
discuss like three broad things one is
the current fi Fiscal Federal landscape
number two is budget requests that
weren't in the governor's recommended
budget third piece is to address some of
the changes in um language we'd like to
address for a prior capital budget
Appropriations then fourth is obviously
to answer any questions may have so the
first part of it is um the current
federal uh fiscal landscape is currently
changing significantly right we are
currently under a continuing resolution
we anticipate a full continued re
resolution for the rest of this Federal
fiscal year um which sometimes sometimes
we'll hamper and limit our budget
Appropriations so we typically have to
compete amongst the 54 states and
territories for your equivalent of
federal dollars what we call military
construction
dollars so when you look at our number
one priority uh it is a Plymouth Armory
a Readiness Center think of it like this
in the competition we facing this
Federal fesal uh Federal Federal uh
fiscal
landscape out of the 54 states and
territories there are over 2,000
armories Across the Nation and only four
are being funded for new construction
and we are one of those
four right that tells you the
significant stress on our armories we
have about approximately 20 armories in
18 communities across the state the
challenge for us is how do you sort of
recapitalize armies that date back to
1880 1932 and invol majority of them in
the 1950s Cold War era we only have
three new armories in the last 20 years
our headquarters building and conquered
a new Readiness Center in Pembrook and
in addition to our conquered uh our
Aviation facility this Plymouth Armory
is a big deal so why is it a big deal in
2019 we became the department of
military Affairs and veteran services so
we were trying to demolish our exist in
Armory on Plymouth College Plymouth
State tear down and build a two brand
new two-story Armory what we want to
include in that is on the uh State side
of it is a uh veteran service officer uh
office and a veteran student lounge you
know service member for a life is a
Demas priority of taking care of our
service members throughout their
Continuum of um service whether they're
currently serving or those that are
veteran population having an Armory
centralized sort of in the mid-north
country on a college campus is
invaluable to us it slid on what we call
the fight the president's future years
defense plan because it slid to the
right in a future outy year which is now
Federal fiscal year 27 we all know like
with home construction the cost of
construction has gone up we need
additional money which we requested Last
by Anum to make sure we can fill the
full square footage of that building
without there will be in a detriment and
we'll have to do sort of bid adjustments
a year and a half from now when we do
this bid opening and we want to build
this new facility that's why it's our
number one priority and that's why it's
a it's a 7525 federal state cost share
$3 million Federal $1 million state
general
funds when you look at the next two
projects on our list uh we leverage
significantly our Congressional
Delegation to get uh or receive
congressionally directed spending
projects they're huge it's a way for us
to sort of um you know leverage
additional funds on behalf of our
service members these two projects here
were requested in federal fiscal year 24
and again in this Federal fiscal year
they're both 100% fredly reimbursed um
they emitted from the governor's
recommended budget and we are here to
Advocate on behalf of them again they're
both 100% feather re URS it's in
addition to our Plymouth Readiness
Center which is relatively new but we
had to put more service members in that
building to take care of uh overcrowding
and other older facilities and then the
third one down on the list is a uh
Aviation hanger
facility so we're fortunate to get to
additional helicopters in our inventory
we're now up to 12 we have two black uh
two Lakota uh helicopters which are
relatively new for the last 6 months and
we have 10 blackhaw helicopters because
of those new helicopters we don't have
hanger space to put them in it's 100%
fly reimburse project we we are pursuing
a congressionally directed spending
project so generally what we need is
we're getting the federal dollars we
just need the state checkbook to put the
money into that's why these two are
relatively important for us so that
explains the three projects that were
not included in the governor's
recommended budget if you go to page six
and seven I believe in your handout is
it that house
bill within House Bill 25 you'll see we
change the language of a couple of
projects generally speaking they're 100%
fed
reimbursed they are associated with
congressionally directed spending
projects ear marks that we have received
from Congress and we're just titing up
the language to ensure that we can
receive the money in the right pot of
the right pot of money and their right
appropriation 100% Federal no
significant changes other than the fact
that we just want to ensure that the
state of New Hampshire dmas can accept
this money from the federal government
facilities so we talked about the
changing Federal landscape our three
additions to the governor's recommended
budget the text that we Chang for two or
three Appropriations in previous house
bills um subject to your questions
that's pretty much all I
questions seriously
okay I just if I if I might just provide
a clarification what the uh General is
asking for is to basically change the
titles of a couple of previously
approved projects so he doesn't want to
use it for the purpose it was derived
for originally he just wants to have it
broaden to a different purpose and they
provided language in two instances for
that so that's not something that has
been changed yet it they're asking to
have that change
made that would be
seven it would be the Pembroke RTI
upgrades and the uh so what they're
asking to have happen there is that the
two projects in the first table one was
anti-terrorism um Force protection the
other was energy res resiliency and
efficiency improvements to change the
titles to those two projects which were
100% federally funded to be the Pembrook
um RTI
upgrade and then on the last page is a
believe from the marac county facility
upgrades to the Stanford count
okay it's on page 7even yep so going
from the warehouse facility upgrades to
the military uh minor military conr
construction straford
County so all it is is just a simple um
change in amending the prior capital
budget um titles with an amendment to
this capital budget if the committee
were to go forward with that questions
representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman so uh thank you General and all
the way um so these two budget items are
basically the same scope of work but
you're changing the titles and just make
sure I end understand that reason or is
it has the scop changed
significantly um sorry I should clarify
that thank you Chris
um we received money uh congressionally
directed spending project to do a solar
PV away array to cut down on our energy
consumption and so we have to change the
text it's the same location but sort of
a different purpose so
Mr chairman if I follow so can you
explain what the scope differences on
these couple of projects so we
understand that uh that would be
appropriate change it's just something
that I guess I would say that the
determination is that there's a bigger
priority now but the funding has already
been allocated to you is that the case
it it's where we're successful in
getting federal funds so it's 100%
failure reimburse so in the first case
um it's the it's they're in the pemr
facility for the on page six and we were
successful in getting a congressional
directed spending
project in essence to changed to end do
improvements to antiterrorism force
protection like building standoff and
then also to do energy resiliency which
is a solar array outside of the building
versus improvements inside the building
thanks very
much and and then on page seven the
change was um uh we were unsuccessful in
acquiring a a build buing uh next to an
an Armory in Franklin which we're going
to do a warehouse expansion So what had
happened is um we actually got funding
to build a new fitness facility in
Center straford again 100% fairly
reimburse we changed the location and
the purpose on that
one any further
questions seeing none would we like to
proceed is there any other changes to
any lapse requests or anything at
all uh no sir
further questions representative jur
thank you Mr chairman so am I
understanding this properly um General
you're not going to do the uh
resiliency and efficiency improvements
instead with that
funding we are uh a little bit it's more
of a function of trying to create the
language to incorporate sort of um the
solar PBR aray outside of the building
that will have secondary impacts of the
resiliency on the inside of the
building okay so you're you're trying to
match the title with the scope yes thank
you you're quite welcome
um further
questions so if I'm correct uh so your
your presentation actually wouldn't even
cover anything that you've already got
the governor's approval for we've just
talked about the three additional ones
that you would like okay and if if I can
sum it up uh you're only only asking for
a million dooll upgrade request because
the rest is all federal
funds would that be fair yes
sir thank you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much
General and uh
Mr Shay do we need any updates from you
uh unless the I mean I can talk about
the email I sent this uh Friday related
to the safety came back with their yes
please
um plate so when they came in and talked
to you last week they had a project that
they were requesting that wasn't part of
the capital budget which was to buy
equipment for the platem purposes it was
a um $2.3 million project almost $2.4
million project they wanted to use on
general fund Appropriations to do that
um you would ask them to go back and to
um get information on how they come up
with that dollar amount in doing so um
one of the vendors they spoke with said
you know in terms of the production
capacity that you currently have um you
wouldn't need to buy two pieces of of
equipment in each case you would only
need one so basically cut the price in
half to about $1.3
million in doing so there's a dedicated
fund it's called the reflectorized plate
fund fund which is used as a revolving
fund that pays for all the materials and
costs associated with the plates that
are issued to the citizens of New
Hampshire um so they believe that fund
would be able to cover any Debt Service
as long as the project stay around the
$1.3 million so it would be in other
funded uh projects similar to what
you've seen with fishing game where they
had uh their Debt Service being paid is
from the fishing game fund this debt
service will be paid from the
reflectorized plate fund
um so that would be up to the committee
and whether it was something that you
thought was appropriate um I did confirm
with the Department to make sure that
they The Debt Service could be paid um
ongoing it wasn't just a oneandone in
terms of uh you know that it would be
yeah we get the money this by any but we
don't know about next by they just feel
with the revenue that they bring in it
would be sufficient to cover the ongoing
Debt Service for the new M
Machinery so next next week when we
actually start on our work sessions on
doing this
I think I would recommend that we take a
hard look at including this money it's
not going to be any bonding money it
won't increase anything that we have to
go out and borrow and uh we can
hopefully add add an item for a change
instead of taking them away
representative kazinski so nice to not
so so the commissioner um I think at
that time and when I talk to them
offline um they're looking at
Alternatives so it may continue in the
prison system in terms of the plate
making it may not it depends on um the
type of Machinery that they're going to
get and um if they could work with the
vendor to actually be the producer the
corrections uh Department would still do
the decals they would do all the
printing related to that but it would be
just the plates themselves they might
not but that's a question that they
haven't answered at the department yet
they're still looking at what they might
do in the long
term
followups
um so they pay the Department of
Corrections
for the service that's provided so they
would still have a an expenditure it
just not might not be going to the
Department of Corrections and that money
that goes to the Department of
Corrections goes into their um
industrial
um okay I'm not going to get the name
completely right but their industrial
program has a dedicated fund that is
used to help fund that that um projects
there um so they wouldn't get that
anymore if they weren't doing the plate
the plates themselves they would
continue to get the decals and the
printing but they may not get the plates
and again that's a question that the
commissioner didn't commit one way or
the other yet when I tried to um ask
that question of
him um just looking forward to
next Tuesday a week from tomorrow uh
when we we're gonna have the public
hearing first for a half hour and then
we'll start into our work session uh are
you going to have our little comparison
worksheets for us um could you also if
you can't make it part of it give us a
like a mini breakdown of all the
uh dollars for the extra requests and
will we will will we have a
uh a dollar total of where we're getting
all the laps money
so to answer your question yes um and
I've been keeping a tab on what agencies
are asking um if it would be helpful for
the committee and it's okay with the
chairs things like the um plate
reflectorized plate I could actually
have an amendment drafted so that people
could actually have a piece of paper and
see what's happening versus the
conversation the understanding of what's
happening with the requests that the
Adit General had in terms of the
repurposing of the titles I mean I could
have an amendment drafted so you could
see that on on um Tuesday next week um
that way you it's understood a little
bit easier for people it's the the
mechanics involved um and it may help
with questions and and the committee
making decisions how how are we looking
with all our budget line number items
for laps have you been keeping up with
that well you got a a big chunk today
which was the Department of Corrections
and prior to that it was just just about
$100,000 I think um we're still waiting
on HHS uh they were going to get back to
us and we get the
157,000 I think from
judicial yep yeah that was a project
that is isn't going forward so it's not
new money but you could repurpose it for
something else yeah just so everybody
knows my intent is the governor came in
at at 143 normally we come in
here we get 130 135 is each year and we
having said that we will normally have
about 50 to 60 items that we can pick
not pick and choose from but that we can
trim we can add to things like that
we're not going to have 50 and 60 items
on this budget so this is going to be
very tight I I'd like to set a goal of
trying to get it in at about 133 as
opposed to 143 but we we've have we've
got some needs and and it might not just
be possible so our my intent on the
first day is to go for all the lwh
hanging fruit to see what what we can
cut what what's just what everybody
agrees to uh there won't be any formal
votes we I've went through all my
paperwork from last year we we do
nothing but straw poles we just figure
out until we're ready to act on the
final
hb25 so that's what we're up and in line
for and uh Mr chair representative CL
quickly next week so next week we're
going to have a formal public hearing
that is that correct a formal public
hearing for a half hour and what we've
been having the last few couple days
last week and this week is presentations
by the agencies on their requests corre
but at this hearing like you're the
prime prime sponsor so you will present
it I'll present the bill yeah and it'll
be a chance for uh supporters of the
capital budget to testify or if there's
any opponents or more members of the
public if they have suggestions to
improve it but what we've been doing is
more of the agency presentations correct
which I believe fi Finance is doing
certain something similar with the
operating budget okay I just want to
clarify especially for newer members of
the committee thank correct thank
you if we have no further questions
we've got a good
I
e
good afternoon being 1:00 back let's
continue the afternoon session of the
presentations for the Governor's capital
budget we will now welcome the
Department of Transportation William
Cass welcome to public
works thank you Mr chair uh for the
record William Cass commissioner new
hamper Dot and with me is Danielle
Finance so I don't know if you have an
order to start with uh or um we can we
we have go ahead with your presentation
we I've talked with representative Jack
we're going to uh probably not have to
go over line by line when we get to your
laps extensions we'll we'll probably be
good with that so just uh just your
Capital project requests very good
perfect thank you so I have a book you
should all have um for the hb25 capital
budget requests and I'm going to talk
primarily off the first page which has
an index of the project uh
requests and just for the record and and
I I believe some of you are familiar but
um we we typically break our um capital
budget requests into uh two categories
based on the funding mix so uh the top
portion of that index of that summary is
relative to uh General funded um uh
capital budget request
which primarily deal with um
Aeronautics uh um Rail and Transit those
are G General funded areas of the
department on the bottom half of that um
summary are the capital budget requests
for the highway fund uh for for Highway
funded capital budget items and that is
generally our um our um Highway
Maintenance and the
do uh own facilities uh involved with
the the maintenance of the highway and
those are Highway funded so we usually
keep them separated and split out that
way when we originally presented to the
uh for the Governor's budget submission
it was a ranked priority of all of them
together so as we get into some of the
um some of the details some of those
priority numbers uh are a little off
because they were all lumped together uh
and in
the approximately 9 months since we
originally compr put together our
capital budget we've we've looked harder
at the priorities and stuff as well too
so this is current to what we're
requesting today so let me start with
the top piece of that uh talking about
the general fund uh capital budget
requests so the governor's uh capital
budget request capital budget re uh
funded one fund item for the Department
$390 for the FTA uh Transit match for
the for the state match to help support
FTA uh funded F FTA is Federal Transit
Authority um Revenue Vehicles so these
are federal funds that that we
um um that we use to fund local or
Community Transit uh
vehicles um and there is some State m
match associated with that about
$390,000 and that was funded so on page
one and page two and page three of the
book uh and I won't go into details it
is there but there is um you know the
summary of why it's
necessary what it's going to and on page
three in particular is a list of the
anticipated um vehicles that that
funding will help um will help Fund in
the next
bium um so that information is is there
in in front of
you moving on I'm going to get to then
the uh couple of areas um that that we
had previously requested but weren't
funded in the governor's budget and the
first one being um the state match for
Federal Aviation
projects um
historically the uh the state capital
budget has funded uh the 5% match of of
the FAA funds that go to um State
airports state federal um federally
funded
airports um so these FAA projects the
typically the typical match is 90%
federal funds 5% State funds and St 5%
local or Community funds um
we if you look on page um let me get to
that you look at at page F page five uh
the sheet that went along with that our
original budget ask was about $4.7
million since that time we have looked
harder and we had the actual FY 24
actuals in in hand so um we've revised
the request to be about $3.6 million
General funds that would leverage about
$65 million of uh Federal Aviation funds
that go to um around 40 or so projects
within the state working on State uh
airport assets um and on
page
um 11 and 12 of of the um
of the book there are two sheets one for
FY 26 one for FY 27 that is a a list of
the um of the projects that would be
done with this funding in the next uh
bium so the need for this is
uh is really for uh to help leverage
these federal funds uh historically we
have always funded a 5% match it has
gone a long way toward accessing the FAA
funds necessary for these airport
capital
projects um most of these projects deal
with uh safety improvements to the
airports as well as infrastructure
improvements mainly infrastructure
maintenance and upkeep state of good
repair um so we would ask for
consideration of that again
traditionally it has historically been
the way these uh uh projects have been
funded one other
um I don't know if it's an odity but one
one other uh aspect of this I guess is
that those $65 million of federal funds
they do flow through the capital budget
we don't have those budgeted elsewhere
in our operational budget again
historically um because they are Capital
Improvements uh the the the federal
funds have have flowed through
um the capital budget along with the
state
match and if there are any questions as
I go along please please go ahead and
stop I'll just I'll just keep going in
uh u in absence of any questions I do
want to be respectful of the commit
time the uh the next two uh priorities
for us on the general fund sign deal
with investment or um maintenance and
repair along state-owned owned uh
railroad
facilities
um we are looking for and this is a this
is an area of really kind of
historic
um lack of investment um State owns
about uh 450 miles of railroad
track uh we have 163 active miles that
typically facilitate tourist EXC
Excursion and Freight rail
Services
um the rail along these state owned
quarters has seen substantial wear um so
part of this part of this budget request
is to have a systematic way of um
investing in upgrading and trying to
bring some of those um quarters uh up to
an industry standard 115 pound rail um
on on within the within the um book on
page um 15 14 and
15 um you can see uh there's a little
bit more detail about why the why this
project is necessary but it also shows
the wear and tear that we are finding on
the state-owned uh rail facilities so
this has been a historic this been an
area of long deferred maintenance and um
it releas some funding to uh uh
systematically get through uh starting
to address these State assets is what
we're
requesting
um similarly P priority three is is very
similar uh replacement of of railroad
ties we do a um very limited amount of
just trying to keep the rails in
service um but um another um part of
this funding to go along with uh some
investment in our state-owned rail
corridors and keep them in service many
of these railroad ties were installed in
dates ranging from the 1920s to the
1950s um they are deteriorated ties that
can't support vertical loads and the and
the and the use that's there today and
uh they continue to they continue to uh
so those are that those are the ones
that we would really uh like
consideration of we have a several other
ones that uh again fall below the line
priority five and six for um abandoned
railroad Corridor repairs and uh Transit
match for um Transit uh facility
buildings but those are lower priority
um but I would ask for consideration for
for the for the top three of our
unfunded um priorities the uh State
match for the FAA projects and the FAA
federal funds and the two uh railroad
repair
items and if there aren't any questions
on that yet
um represent
voger thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question on the
um how much would that approximately $2
million uh cover in replacement of the
you said we
have 63 163 active miles yes and how
many of the 163 active miles would that
help out so that uh 1.9 million would
would uh purchase about 4 track miles of
rail um and systematically replacing
that and we would focus that on the on
the on the worst areas of rail in the in
the areas that have the most frequent
use right now we would Target it for
areas of the um Conway Scenic Railroad
which um the mountain division um up up
in that
area followup please follow
up how many of the 163 mil house is in
need or carries the 85
pound uh
rail uh I'm not I'm not sure I'm gonna
ask if anybody behind me if uh our
director do you know
Shelly yeah Mo most of it probably but
uh it's probably been through
any um maintenance type of repairs that
that it would have been different from
the 85 PB rail to the 115 PB rail
representative kazinsky
yes thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions I have a few
questions if you don't mind so the
location you don't have a set location
on on this repair
then not specifically we would Target
the the the most um the most um area
most disrepair but I know we would focus
it on the on the U Mountain division
branch is that right Shel do you have a
specific area yes this is Shelley
Winters our director of Aeronautics rail
Transit so uh we were targeting the the
Conway the section that Conway cck
operates tourist Excursion on on the
state owned Mountain division we have
the exact mile poost to mile poost we
can um give that to the committee if
it's helpful but again tourist Excursion
brings about 75% of the revenue into the
state brings for the the special
railroad fund and as well as brings a
lot of Tourism into the state in general
so we're targeting that that's the most
willfully um in need of Maintenance
right now is the section com SE runs
up so does any uh is any of it uh rail
is used by the freight companies the
private freight companies that use the
rail right now there would just be a
little bit of through Freight on there
that line and the section that Conway
Scenic um is a tenant Railroad on is
looking to bring more Freight in we're
looking for coexistence of Freight in
tourist Excursion railroad so it's to
accommodate the current use safely to
move people and then to accommodate
Freight in the near
term okay because I was hearing about an
investment and I was wondering like how
much we receive the state receives in in
rent or cost covering our cost
cooperating agreements with with them I
don't so tourist Excursion railroads um
provide 20% of their gross operating 10%
is a user fee paid to the state and to
the special railroad fund and a minimum
of 10% goes into maintenance of the
trackage that they um essentially have
they lease from us so do the freight
rails pay anything Freight rail pays 5%
user fee to the state and 20% of their
gross operating for maintenance so it's
a 25% net gross operating for Freight
Excursion yeah and again that yields to
the special railroad Fund in the form of
user fees about
$700,000 a year that we reinvest through
the special Railroad Fund in the state
online so again 700,000 for dollars for
200 miles of active track 163 miles
which get used on a roughly a daily
basis during peak season um is
inadequate for our needs thus the
you does that help I guess
so any other
so moving on to the second the second
section of our uh capital budget request
is the highway fund uh section so um we
had a number of prioritized requests uh
in the governor's budget only uh funded
the the highest priority our top
priority was for a annual project or a I
should say a biannual project banial
project to uh construct um construct uh
sand and salt sheds so the dot we are a
Statewide operation we have around 85 to
90 uh Statewide facilities um Service uh
within any any two or three towns
generally has a highway patrol shed
that's responsible for those um areas of
State Highway usually each Patrol shed
has several out buildings sand shed salt
shed um keep that those materials
undercover so it's an ongoing constant
um um basis of of trying to keep up with
with the with the life of those needs so
we have his have historically had a uh
um a banial project to um systematically
keep up with the uh replacement of those
older facilities sand and salt sheds and
our top budget item here was was for a
uh $3 million fund fund uh funding
request uh to continue that that effort
we anticipate that $3 million will um
address two to possibly three um
facilities I will note that um this was
our request I know when it came through
the budget through the governor's
capital budget it got it got bumped up
to about $4.6 million that's what you
probably see in the capital budget item
before you um we would we would propose
capping it at this $3 million um level
uh we will manage the projects we will
manage the uh activities to that to that
level um within some of the um within
some of the previous approved Capital
items are are are are um some residual
funds that we will seek to bring forward
uh to um continue to work and address
these
facilities that would leave you with uh
1.65 million out of that original 4.6
I'm sure you have uh projects
identified yes continuing down the um
continuing down the list of
priorities um and I would say just as a
as a preface to that one one thing
you're right the the difference between
that 4. and what we're requesting here
um I will also point out that in our
operating budget we had again this was
done back uh last summer when we first
did the capital budget request we have
budgeted uh Debt Service in our
operating budget um Highway fund Debt
Service that would support about $10
million of capital uh investment so
where you see this line here drawn we
have targeted our capital budget request
toward that about $10 million limit
because we do feel it is supported um by
The Debt Service that we are budgeting
in our operating budget so um I put that
out there for the committee's
consideration as well
too
um so the second um so the second
priority there would be uh very similar
to uh the sand and salt sheds would be a
$2 million banial investment in
Statewide wide underground fuel tank
Replacements I had mentioned about the
85 to 90 facilities around the state uh
not only do they have uh sand and salt
sheds most of those have some sort of
fueling capacity um whether it's diesel
or diesel and and and gas um and we uh
again it's a constant investment to keep
up to code to keep up uh to keeping good
graces with our Dees permitting for
these these
facilities um so this $2 million would
go to reconstruction of the oldest and
the highest risk storage and
Distribution Systems Statewide um we
have four or five um higher priority
facilities in the pictures
are of those facilities are you know
shown in the um in the budget request
book on page 34 and 35 just to give you
a sense of of of where uh and uh we
would Target those Investments and some
pictures of of what those existing um
dated facilities uh look like so you can
see some of the ones that we're looking
at uh replacing or rehabilitating are
are one are facilities that are 35 36
years old um and in quite a bit of Need
moving um along the next highest
priority uh priority number three uh
it's about $1.2 million to uh replace
the garage roof on our Twin Mountain
shed um again that is an older shed the
roof has been in
um um disrepair for some time uh it is a
much older facility um the current roof
design
uh back in the 70s when we were doing
these designs they they rely on on the
heating of the building to melt the snow
on the roof the roof isn't really
structurally adequate to hold snow loads
which is strange considering it's in
Twin Mountain the North country north of
the N where we get a lot more snow um
fuel efficiencies and stuff like that
are are just um not really uh
sustainable uh as well as the age and
everything with the roof
um in other smaller facilities we do
look within our operational budget with
our own State forces to to do roof
Replacements and stuff if if we can uh
again this is a much larger Capital
project due to the size of facility the
age of the facility the structural type
of work that would be um required to um
uh replace this existing roof uh so this
um and finally uh priority number four
um which I again would utilize most of
the rest of again that $10 million
threshold that I had targeted would be
for the replacement of the uh lempster
uh Patrol shed
again I don't want to sound like a
broken record but we do have uh
facilities uh uh across the state
somewhere in the order of 85 to 90
Patrol sheds and uh again historically
we've tried to Target at least one
Patrol shed per vium to to um seek to
replace and and and address if uh if
we're able to do that then you know
we're on a replacement cycle of of well
over a hundred years which is not
probably ideal not really um tenable but
at least keeping up with the worst of
the worst um last bium we did not again
time times were tight in the budget and
looking at things we did not um have a
uh Patrol shed uh funded for some other
life safety Investments and things that
needed to go on to meet fire code and
things like that um but in this bium um
to keep from falling further behind in
our uh Building Maintenance and
replacement cycle we'd like to talk
Target at least this one oldest Patrol
shed in our inventory for replacement
and the building replacement costs do
continue to to increase um and this is a
a fairly um substantial investment of
about $3.5
million um and along those lines the the
next highest priority is a patrol shed
and Pinkham Notch
um we whether whether whether whether
there would be funding or or not we
would at least like to begin the
planning and some initial design work on
on what a um facility for that next
highest priority Patrol shed would um
would look like and what it might cost
so um that would be the residual uh
amount of the funding that priority
number five pink and Patrol facility uh
preconstruction um for whatever would
last with than our targeted $10 million
uh
request and some of the pictures for
those facilities are shown on within the
book on page
um and the Pinkham shed beginning on
page
45 so it's been just about a half hour
that um that uh kind of concludes a very
high level summary of the of our budget
request there is a lot of information
in in the book so hopefully any your
questions about these uh requests are
are answered there but I'll certainly
ask entertain any further questions MREs
CL okay thank you Mr sh can you tell me
commissioner exactly where the patrol
shed in lster is
located uh I I can it's on Route 10
Route 10 south of uh
it's it's um yeah it's on Route 10 uh
it's a it's at the southerly limits of
District Two and the Northerly you know
just over the line from I think Marlo
and and District uh two okay and just I
used to represent that
Community I figured it but I just want
to be absolutely thank you commissioner
thank you you're welcome any further
questions repres representative
Boger thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question you might
have answered this and I just didn't
hear it and or didn't register on uh
your priority number two the underground
storage tanks uh how many tanks would
the $2
million
replace I saw the list
over
on of Tanks but
my I don't want to assume if that covers
all of those or not and so I was just
curious um it's a a hard question to
answer um I know when we just did a
facility that that was just built up in
Pittsburgh it was about $800,000 to do a
full tank replacement and that was a a
full distribution site um some of the
ones pictured here are are are diesel
only um it may not be the full tanks it
may be the um the tank top and the um
and the um um dispenser type of type of
system to be Co code so would be
substantially less um I don't know I'll
ask um Dave do you have any better uh
details on that or I think you it two to
three sites two to three sites and Dave
is our assistant commissioner so Dave
rodrigue thank you you're welcome
representative Jack uh thank you I've
had the opportunity to look through the
laps uh document that you and my my uh
figures match exactly with the one
exception I'm not sure if you covered
this earlier we wanted to to have an
extension for the Carol and straford
improvements that uh this is 2023 Roman
15 number
three I think that's outside no it's
part of
D that uh former chairman Campbell had
asked had had asked about
250,000 I I don't have the amount here
but whatever you say it's uh it is in
process it's 202 pulling forward but
it's encumbered so the work Isen all
right well we'll add an extension for it
if that's all
right like to bring your attention to to
the last two items on that list as
well I'm sorry I'd like to bring your
attention to the last two items on that
list as well um these are very old items
they were for the railroad acquisition
first right of refusal and for um
acquisition of railroad airport
properties and there hasn't been
activity in in these lines in quite a
bit that they're like holders they
holders those if you're referencing
207 so our thought with that would be to
repurpose those funds um and use the
funds for our priorities to uh
uh perhaps Mr chairman we could ask them
for a document that we could consider at
the work session yes uh okay um we're
going to meet next Tuesday if we could
have some sort of documentation for our
first work session we're going to start
going through the add-ons and deletions
and we need some some more exact figures
and we're just going to roll it over
okay okay any anything else
representative Jack uh that's all I have
on this
agency representative
Boyd thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my questions uh duve tailing
off of Representative boger's question
regarding the underground storage tanks
has there been any conversation about
filling those tanks up with cement or
with sand and finding a new location for
the the specific um finding someplace on
the on the property where the new tanks
installed I guess I'm not I I I don't
quite understand you're looking to
replace those those gas tanks correct
sure yes so instead of removing them out
of the ground was a conversation had
either filling them up with sand or
cement and sealing them and shutting it
off so that another suitable location
could be picked for your free gas tank
as part of the design work when we do a
new a new fuel site uh we do look on
site for the most
advantageous uh way of doing it we have
and and other recent projects um
Consolidated locations within within a
region or between two or three Patrol
sheds um on the site specific uh we
wouldn't just um unless it made the most
sense we wouldn't just uh replace it
right right in kind there we would look
to do it in the most advantageous place
um and as far as just uh filling with
sand or or concrete um I'm I'm not sure
if the um if the current reg if the
regulations would would allow for that I
do believe there is some uh remediation
when when uh underground fuel tanks are
removed to to ensure that they are um
done and there's no leakage and stuff
like that but uh we would look to do it
as
as in the most economic means possible
thank you thank you Mr chairman
representative jurus thank you Mr
chairman commissioner in the replacement
of the the garages or uh or roofs have
you considered photovoltaics on those
roofs considered what photovoltaics on
those phot take solar on those roofs to
net meter yes we have okay we we did a
uh uh a patrol shed uh Rehabilitation
right in right in Manchester off
101 uh and as part of and as part of
that um I think we added one one Bay and
had had renovated the the patrol shed
and as part of that there were solar
panels added to the roof um to help um
mitigate the energy costs thank you
you're
welcome thank you seeing no further
questions I'm sorry representative
Edgar I just thank you has a final
question thank you Mr chair I was just
waiting to see if somebody's going to
ask a question I was going to ask
um could uh I appreciate you helping me
with the answers to this I'm looking at
the summary you gave us on the guess
guess it's page one or it's on uh minus
one you have um the different the state
match for the FAA projects and you got a
A Transit match um they total up to you
know 7 million something now is it true
that by your documentation here that we
would uh forfeit sense like
$70,000 7 $70 million of of stuff that
we're going to match are we going to
able to do anything at the airports or
am I reading this wrong no you're
reading it right that that is that is
part of the ask here that it does uh put
those federal funds in Jeopardy if there
not a viable way of of meeting the match
requirements so we letting whether 60
years $70 million worth of of projects
we could have got done uh that the feds
would have paid for by by not matching
it yes I just wanted to to highlight
that
um I have follow thank you Mr
chair uh on the the highway fund items
most of them are not being requested are
you right now it looks like you're only
requesting the uh the top one uh salt
shacks and stuff are you the top one was
funded in the governor's budget so so
the Statewide uh salt and sand sheds was
funded in the governor's budget it was
funded for a little bit more than than
what we had here it's funded at $ 4.65
million we're we're we're suggesting
we're recommending we're requesting uh
$3 million and we would work within it
um where we drew a Gray Line there below
uh priority number five um I I I had
pointed out at the beginning in our
operations budget we we have uh The Debt
Service uh budgeted over the next bium
that would support um you know a$ 10
million capital investment here so I I
targeted uh a $10 million capital budget
ask for the highway fund um portion of
this but there are certainly more needs
than than that I I
I but I'm trying to be realistic in what
I know our budget will support as well
yeah we got all this so shows quite a
bit but the uh so you you feel um
comfortable with uh with the Department
of Transportation taking on as much as
10 million uh spending that much out of
the trust fund excuse me out of the
highway fund the needs are really there
and you would prefer that yes yes in the
priority shown yes okay thank you very
much thank
you see no further questions thank you
very much thank you
all next I'd like to call up
uh David Campbell for a
request it's regarding some we've got a
extensions thank you Mr chairman members
of the uh Public Work committee always
good to be back in room 2011 my name's
David Campbell represent the New
Hampshire North Coast railroad uh do you
want me to address the lapses very very
quickly very quickly please um so the
contract that was signed for the last
capital budget $250,000 of State funds
matching 250,000 of of nhn funds that
contract was signed August until August
30th by the governor and Council they
put in that agreement that it would be
um that's that the period to perform is
through December 31st of 201
2 it's not consistent with legislation
LBA recommended that it be extended to
2025 to line up with the agreement and I
think that's what the commissioner and
um representative Jack were just talking
about how out on that representative
Jack okay yeah that's that's the item
that I spoke about
earlier uh so you know this committee
and both representative Democratic uh
Led Led legislatur have included
matching funds for New Hampshire's
Freight railroads in the last F Five
Capital budgets 2017 on and for that the
New Hampshire North Coast is very
thankful um the upkeep of railroad
infrastructure and the challenges facing
all Shortline railroads including the
state just heard um is is daunting and
and it faces not only us but uh all
shortland railroads and and and 40% of
all Freight in America all rail Freight
I should say is is hollowed by Shortline
railroads not just the main lines these
are the these are the veins that go off
the arteries and that's where the that's
where the businesses are um I sent a
link last week for an historical
documentary that we prepared it's part
of a a Federal grant it's 40 minutes
long but it goes fast believe it or not
and uh it does
show interestingly through over 150
years before the Civil War through the
Civil War through World War I the
depression the of the automobile World
War II it does it does show that the one
thing that drives railroads drives this
thing is you have to have a
commodity that makes the railroad work
you got to have something whether it's
ice or uh or passengers or you know ski
ski
trains uh or Timber it has to be
something that drives it for the last uh
50 years it's been it's been sand and
gravel and Propane
um and that's because the cost of
maintaining tracks has always been will
always be expensive probably
disproportionately so now um so I just
wanted to mention that before I get into
and I'm not going to go through this
whole thing because it's Alli there for
you but I just want to tell you the
first slide tells what we are for those
that aren't familiar with us we're a 42
mile Short Line railroad we run from
Rollinsford up to oopy um strictly
strictly uh um Freight the second slide
talks about the largest commodity is
concrete sand second is propane propane
comes in to the facility in Rochester
where it's distributed goes into the
storage facility and it's distributed by
trucks all over the region Eastern
Propane sec I think the second largest
uh propane company in New Hampshire um
they're very supportive uh their vice
president sent a letter of support and
and gives his reasonings why and let you
read that for yourself of the concrete
say about approximately 38 40% of it
goes to Rochester not all the way to
Boston just to Rochester for the for the
concrete plants in that region and the
other and the rest goes to Boston the
propane comes in this year because of
the cold I think they're going to do
over well over 800 cars um it's so
important because by save by saving
money uh for for the import of propane
uh that's pass the LA to Consumers the
cost goes up if they do it by truck not
only is it is it cost less cost
effective and not efficient
environmentally in every other way um it
would drive the price of of of fuel of
propane up um the transloading facility
is is pictured on page
four
um the freight railroad takes a lot of
truck traffic off the road uh 40,000
roundt trips of heavy trailer or tanker
trucks come off the road every year
because of of the freight that's hauled
by New Hampshire North Coast
uh taking 1.7 million heavy truck trips
off highways over the last 37 years is
pretty incredible that has dramatically
increased fuel efficiency discre discre
decreases carbon emissions greatly
improves highway safety which from your
Vantage Point significantly reduces wear
and tear on highways Municipal roads and
it saves on maintenance
costs so uh slide six just kind of goes
over the scope of of the maintenance and
repairs the numbers are there 247,000
ties uh and it shows the cost and the
next slide too addresses you know what's
going on as far as the um amount of
infrastructure needs to be addressed and
we've been fortunate to
have the state of New Hampshire be
supportive of great railroad throughout
the years New Hampshire and North Coast
wouldn't exist wasn't for the funding uh
contributions that's made Through The
Years by the state and the federal
government private businesses have given
money including the Eastern Propane and
the municipalities they they they
participated um a lot in the various
years so uh slide eight is just the
history of the state of state grants um
going back to
2017 the probably the 10 years prior to
that 12 years prior prior to that the
only state funds other than State
administered Crossing grants it's a
federal program it was probably $150,000
for the state put into a multi-million
dollar tiger
Grant the ninth slide ninth slide talks
about um current Chrissy Grant we have
which is dressing rails ties Ballance
replacement a Crossing upgrade but more
importantly in Rochester there's the
Haven Hill Bridge which has been struck
so many times and there's pictures of it
in some of the documents it just keeps
getting hit by by trucks it comes in
groups and then it doesn't happen for
for years and it does um it is a it is a
real problem it was built in the 1800s
and it's not high enough we're going to
raise that this year as part of that
Grant but there's 32 other Bridges and
scores of stone and granite culverts uh
in fact what we're asking for this year
is is is one of the really amazing
architectural features historical
features on the rail it's this Arch
Bridge and you can see pictures of it in
the upcoming slides that Arch Bridge was
replaced a 200 foot long uh Timber span
back in the 1800s and they built this
thing it's basically a Roman Roman Arch
and it uh it's held up very well but
it's it needs to be repointed the
problem is because it is in this
precarious Place o over 200 feet stretch
um Great Brook is called the Milton
Milton and because of that uh it has to
go down steep slopes and it's very
expensive to get to it immobilize so
that is part of this year's tiger Grant
request
which I show you how and our request
today is for respectfully asked for
$450,000 in state funds to match
$450,000 in in match money to address
these four items ver is that Stone Arch
Bridge which a total estimat about
438,000
then there's a covert replacement which
you can see the picture of which is
pretty
much which is pretty much collapsed
Mainline switch there's a diagram of how
complicated that is and how big that is
um and then there's a Crossing placement
in Wakefield it's one of the longest
Crossings and it's because it I'm sorry
it's Wayfield Street in Rochester it's
one of the longest Crossings and it
diagonally crosses uh Wakefield Street
and it's you can't see it on top but the
whole subsurface all the old ties are
rotting out underneath it that's not
only just a that's that could shut down
the rail line but it could also um cause
problems with the motoring power public
and I think as
um Bob LEF says in his letter of
endorsement for us today which we
appreciate he says that and he
rightfully so he says a railroad is like
a a a chain it's only as strong as its
weakest link if a bridge goes out
Crossing goes out there's no railroad
nothing can go back and forth so there's
some pictures to show it what we are
asking for and with that I would uh sum
up and uh and finish and answer any
questions thank you
kazinski yeah your mic's
off
so at lunch I was just looking at a
couple of figures and I see that Freight
rail is actually the most profitable
business in the United States
approximately 50% profit so the owner of
this track this private rail is Boston
sand and gravel
right correct they own they own New
Hampshire North Coast railroad right
so what's their revenue for a year
anyway I I can't tell you that but I can
tell you unequivocally that they don't
make 50% profit that they barely make
profit if they make profit on that
railroad every year that I can that I
know and and that's because of the
extreme cost of of the infrastructure uh
it I mean we could always do more but we
don't we do as much as we can do to keep
the railroad operating uh they are they
also own usby agregates which is their
big biggest customer so as a result you
know asby agregates gets to make some
money businesses have to make money no
business in America continues to operate
unless it makes some kind of money or at
least breaks even enough to to to cause
another company to make money uh I'm not
privy or not able to give you exact
figures but
I I I would dispute strongly that all
railroads make 50 great railroads make
50% they all struggle to make profits
and I I can say without a doubt that New
profit I guess well I don't want to get
into the debate here but yeah we're not
we're not going to have a debate on this
but so thank you questions will be
answered asked and answered no
debate representative
thank you Mr chairman a quick question
I'm just trying to figure out the
propane where does so the you move the
propane from where to where and where
where does that propane come from is it
coming down from
Maine lot of comes from selker New York
there's a big there's a big natural gas
head there or a propane head there that
they they bring it in um and then it's
redistributed throughout the Northeast
from cerk a lot of it comes from cerk I
know that because I see the slips so it
comes on the main line CSX hauls it to
Rollinsford where it's switched on to
the to our line and we bring it up
actually it's a little more comp it
actually goes all the way to Portland
yeah because of down Easter and the and
the uh conflict of schedules it goes all
the way to Portland to their yard and
then when they have a chance they run
special trains down to Rollinsford to
switch to North Coast North Coast
accommodates them immediately and brings
yard thank you very much for your uh
presentation Mr Campbell thank you
members of the committee thank you Mr
chairman uh run it a little bit behind
but I'm sure we'll get caught up here
let's hear from the Department of
welcome to public works please proceed
wonderful thank you my name is Sarah
Stewart and I serve as the commissioner
of the Department of Natural and
cultural
resources um we're thrilled to be here
today this department is made up of the
division of Parks and Recreation the
division of forest and lands the New
Hampshire State Library the division of
historical resources and the New
Hampshire State Council on the Arts New
Hampshire is a state that is known for
its natural beauty Amazing Outdoor
Recreation vibrant cultural activity and
our commitment to honoring our past
these are the natural and cultural
resources we are proud to protect
promote and manage and it is with your
support that we can create the best
experiences for our citizens and
visitors our department cares for 884
buildings 22 Bridges 26
dams 147 septic systems
1,427 campsites a fleet of 298 vehicles
and many collections that are include
that include rare Irreplaceable and
valuable items
these valuable items are primarily
stored at the New Hampshire State
Library uh but they're also tucked
within various other locations around
the state like at our headquarters State
Park and State Forest offices and our
historic
sites thanks to the support of our
legislature over the years we have made
much progress tackling deferred
maintenance but we still have more to do
we must also acknowledge the millions of
arpa dollars allocated by this agency we
have been able to purchase brand new
snowmobile trail groomers develop plans
for campsite expansions replace very old
and outdated bathroom facilities and
tackle some long overdue revenue revenue
generating upgrades an example is the
antique infrastructure at our state
Nursery that we will discuss with you
today we presented a forward-thinking
$37.5 million Capital Improvement
project request list last year to the
sonunu
administration this request addressed
our goals of stewardship safety
infrastructure and new
development Capital Investments allow us
to upgrade our extensive infrastructure
to sustain our capacity to generate
outside revenue and balance our
operating budget this agency is looking
at an 11% cut of our general fund
allocation in the upcoming biennium
advancing in our in our Revenue
opportunities is critical so that we can
be nimble for instance a healthy Park
fund allows us to absorb the costs of
the Bureau of historic sites without
compromising access and proper
management we deeply appreciate Governor
aot's support for investing in this
agency most importantly her support for
the aerial Tramway at Franconia Notch
State Park and we are prepared to talk
through this with you
today with an emphasis on maintaining
our current infrastructure and reducing
our backlog of deferred maintenance we
prioritized our initial request into 11
priorities number one the Tramway number
two the State Library off-site storage
design three forest and lands facilities
four Roofing and repairs five roads and
parking lots six toilet building up
toilet building upgrades seven Canon
lodges eight historic sites nine SE
Coast planning and resilience 10 amog
State Park Marina and Facilities 11
Connecticut headquarters Road repair now
we know that all of these priorities
cannot be realized in one capital budget
by anym but we feel it's our
responsibility as managers of the
state's natural and cultural resources
to be fully transparent with you about
where we believe the state's Investments
are most urgent we are seeking to
address fundamental needs to establish
and maintain our facilities up to a
standard worthy of our visitors with the
hope of maximizing Revenue opportunities
throughout our great state safety and
quality of experience requires proper
care and upkeep and we appreciate your
thoughtful consideration of our
priorities I know you have a lot to go
through today so I thought we would
start with what we feel are our most
critical needs um and I invited our
director of state parks to address the
aerial Tramway at
Canon I think we should start with the
aerial Trailway at Canon that would be
great that would be great so I'm going
to ask um Brian Wilson to walk you
through how we got to where we are today
with the Tramway situation and where we
think we need to
go thank you commissioner again my name
is Brian Wilson I'm the director of the
division of Parks and Recreation oversee
the state park system the Bureau of
trails uh Franco unaj State Park and
Canon Mountain uh and a bureau of
historic
sites uh the Canon Mountain Tramway uh
2.0 is the current Tramway that we have
in place which has been operating for 46
years now about six years ago uh we were
uh put on notice from the uh uh
manufacturer that uh it was approaching
its end of life and certain components
of uh the tram system were not going to
be able to be remade should they uh have
a failure at some point in time at that
time the department um started putting
into their capital budget requests uh
funding uh based on estimates provided
at that time now that's over six years
ago and clearly the uh cost estimates um
have uh ES ated over that time for all
the factors that everything that you
guys are uh taking before you through
your Capital
oversight
um it in uh in the last BM Governor
sonunu had uh put in $18 million uh for
the aerial Tramway um after there was a
request for 25 million from the agency
uh at that time uh the $25 million
request at the time was uh based off of
the best estimates that we had at the
time and knowing that we had some but
not a lot of available resources within
the division of parks through some uh
Grand oportunities as well as excess
operating Revenue that we were uh
willing to put towards uh the project to
see it through we went through a very
complex and um lengthy bidding process
for the aerial Tramway um and we
received one bid result um that was $33
million um at that that time we were
essentially forced to reject the bid um
with18 million in hand uh and the cost
of the project for 33 million it's
important to note that within that bid
there was other work that was uh uh part
of the specifications which was uh
restoration and a uh painting
application to the steel infrastructure
at the uh base and Summit lodges as well
as the three towers that are between the
base and the summit that support the
Tramway system um what we also found
through this bidding process was the uh
one of the two uh prospective biders
opted to not bid on the project uh but
instead provided us a in-depth memo um
pointing out areas that they thought
that our bid specific bid specifications
fell short um of describing current
conditions for them to be able to make
uh Structural Engineering decisions um
we work very closely with the division
of Public Works on this project they
administr it and so from that point we
have been sharpening our pencils and
moving towards a structural engineering
assessment uh which is going to be going
out to bid uh within the next couple of
weeks Public Works and uh Parks have
been working on that for almost a year
to try to win down to really uh get down
to the information that we thought was
uh critical to getting uh more more bids
but hopefully more thorough bids and and
potentially uh has the opportunity of um
a cleaner bid to come in at at a at a
reduced
cost um within uh Governor aot's budget
um within the capital budget she has
appropriated $20 million for this
project also within the general fund
operating budget for the state um she
has proposed um re uh having the $18
million that have already been
appropriated by Governor sonunu laps
back so that means um we are $2 million
closer to seeing this Pro project
completed uh than we were two years ago
um but we also know that it it is likely
to be a $30 million project no matter
what so we're we're at a juncture here
uh at at this stage um short of further
structural
assessment um with um a considerable Gap
in in in the funding to get us all the
way enough for Public Works to be able
to go bid this project again uh they
need to be we need to be able to show
them that the funding is available based
on the last best estimate um so we're
we're short of that so um even with the
20 million that's in the capital budget
we're there's not very much that we're
going to be able to do with that we
can't build a half of a aerial Tramway
uh so we're trying to Value engineer
this project to the best extent that we
can um but it it it is really uh kind of
an All or Nothing
project um why we're at a critical point
here in this vium and the decisions that
this committee and the legislature needs
to to make uh at this time is six years
ago we were put on notice from the
manufacturer um we are rapidly losing
ground relative to our our time to be
able to operate the existing Tramway um
this will be the first time in the
history of Canon Mountain that we would
be looking at the potential of
decommissioning ayt um especially of the
size and scale as the aerial Tramway and
what it brings into Franconia Notch and
uh perhaps you know just as importantly
as our op operating Revenue that is
derived from the operation of the tram
particularly in the summer and fall
Seasons generates over a million dollars
annually that help support the ski
area's operation so what will happen
when the tram goes offline if we get to
a point where it goes offline is we will
see immediate impacts to uh the way that
Canon Mountain uh operating budget is
structured um when we will not be able
to offer the same types of services uh
that we offer now um we had hoped that
we wouldn't get to a point where we were
um going
offline um but that we would be under a
the planning and construction phase to
help coincide with that um so with each
passing opportunity to fund this project
um our our window of opportunity gets a
little bit shorter on that not to say
that a tra could have be done at some
point well into the future as well to
but what will certainly happen is when
it does go offline we will start to see
immediate impacts both within the park
in terms of operating and visitation uh
and again as the commissioner said
earlier as the state park system is
entirely self-funded we are very ring on
the infrastructure that we have in the
Parks uh to be able to uh receive the
visitors the visitors that we get um
Canon mountain is a Statewide attraction
it is it is known you know for
Generations now uh there are people from
all over the world that are coming to
visit um our our White Mountains and
they're they're often going to try to
get to the top of Mount Washington or to
get to the top of another over 4,000
footer which is Canon Mountain so this
is a very big uh project for us um and
um I'm happy to answer any questions
specific to that but I just wanted to
kind of lay out a little the background
of where we are
today I'm sure we're going to have
questions I'm going to ask the first one
out of the 20 out of the 20 million
which you admit is is not going to fund
this
completely and I'm I'm hoping I already
know the answer to this have you looked
into into breaking it down to where the
you know we do a lot of projects that
are going to take five six seven years
have have you looked into breaking it
down into any smaller chunks in other
words could we get you five million that
would would get a design would get a a a
full operational dollar cost that that
we could count on
um so um I think the my answer would be
uh this is All or
Nothing All or Nothing project but I
think that there there are some
strategic ways that it could either be
um carried over uh to bium for instance
um that that that's a possibility there
um there is also some um I I I remain
confident that there are some other
creative ways that we can close the gap
on that for instance um we have the um
what we utilize very heavily uh to
upkeep the infrastructure Canon mountain
is a Canon Mountain Capital Improvement
fund which is the proceeds that we get
from the the the lease at sunap Mountain
on average that's going to be around
$700,000 a year that we getting that is
immediately going right back into
infrastructure improvements but the idea
is that we have a bonding um line of
credit up to $6 million uh to be able to
access and itiz for ongoing Capital
Improvements within the park a model
like that where uh even a portion of
revenue generated from the operation of
the tram or from the park is going to
help pay down that debt service is an
option I think um we are using a similar
model at the Sea Coast for the U seaw
wall on Ocean Boulevard that is State
Park infrastructure that was millions of
dollars to build a seaw wall our parking
revenue is supporting the the the pay
pay of those Bond payments what needs to
happen is a conversation of collective
Minds that want to see this project get
done um I I think that there's some
other measures through federal grants
that we have opportunities to apply to
um leveraging resources within the park
fund and and perhaps offsetting uh from
some of the revenue generation at the
park I think can close the gap so I
think there's a there's there's a little
bit of a platter of options um there
just needs to be a real concerted to
work towards what is the right path
forward thank you very much for that
answer representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I just want to
make sure I'm clear on this I've heard a
number of numbers over the last couple
weeks on what the what has been funded
for this project on your page two on
Capital Improvements it it indicates a
line end with $15 million I'm correct
right and then we were told that the
prior appropriation was for $18 million
and you're a now asking for 20 million
and before I forget I think we had also
spoken in one of the previous meetings
about reuse to repair of the existing
Towers to make sure that we could um
complete this project so like to make
sure that we're we're doing that but I'm
also trying to figure out what number
we're actually working with what number
the governor has said and what number
you guys are using right now because I
got three numbers in my head yep great
question so um the the $1 15 million
that you see in our request was to be in
addition to the $18 million that a year
ago when we made this request we had in
hand so that combined was going to bring
us to the $33 million which was the cost
of the one bid that we got so that is
the 15 is a little less than half of
what we had um already available to us
to get to the full project completion
the um the 20 number is um I I I don't
know what um if that's arbitrary or
where that came from uh within the
governor's budget um but that is what
she she put in as a placeholder uh to to
hopefully you know start get us most of
the way there um but I I'll use the word
arbitrary in a sense because that's not
tied to any specific thing that we asked
for um and um sorry there was one other
missing number there the the so the
assurances that the concrete is viable
in the future should help reduce the
cost right but we can't prove that until
we go through this assessment that we're
working with DPW currently so there's a
there's a there's a time frame overlap
with the 18 million that was allocated
to us it's being taken away from us but
before June we've already been working
on this bid to assure to get an
engineers's assessment and assurance
that the concrete towers are sturdy
enough for the future so we'd like to
proceed with that we're working with DPW
to move forward with that so that'll
take a little bit out of the 18 million
before it goes back although I think
it's achieved some interest so it should
wash out um that's going back to the
general fund and then Governor aot
realizing that's going back to the
general fund put in the 20 million that
we're talking about today and we're
explaining to you that that's not going
to be enough as is does that help it
does and and you actually clarified when
you added that 15 to the 18 about the 33
million total had I had heard you say
that but with the three numbers I just
wanted to make sure what it is so along
with that then when what how much money
do you need to get to where we can feel
comfortable with with what you need to
complete the project and when would that
uh be
forthcoming well um so the the the
structural engineering assessment that
the commissioner was just speaking to is
going to be starting to to to happen
this this spring and summer uh so
through that by probably by late summer
we will have more data available to us
to that we can then reincorporate that
into our bid specifications for the
larger project but I I think it's safe
to say that this is going to be a $30
million project I think if it if it ends
up being 35 I think some of the internal
solutions that through our own agency
income and federal grants that we can we
can probably come up with a with a five
million within our own agency um if
that's going to be what it takes to to
get this project over the goal line uh
the 20 that we have now is is is is
short um so I would say 30 million is
really the number that we're we're
hoping to get to um and again my the
other opport other ways to potentially
if it's not through Capital
appropriation then perhaps there's other
means to do that quick followup Mr
chairman followup so with this new work
that we're doing now with looking at the
towers and the information you got from
that second bidder do you think we're
going to be able to get more than one
bidder on this project now yes that that
was really the whole goal in part of
this exercise as well too to have some
competition within within the bids yes
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman representative
alone thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
particular taking my question so on the
revenue side have you considered raising
rates to be a part of this process of
solving the problem and if so what what
are you what are you talking about in
terms of of bottom line figures yes
great question so yes we have considered
that um as as I think most folks know so
the way that the park system is operated
is operationally we're self-funded so
all the revenue that we generate goes
back into the operation and there's
certain levels of Maintenance and and
upkeep that are that are part of the
Canon Mountain operation that happened
through their operating dollars but the
capital side of things whether it's for
new bathroom buildings new parking lots
new ski lifts is separate from our
operating budget so there is not um
really a
mechanism where we're um taking Revenue
um that from our operating budget and
putting it towards capital budget
however the like the seaw wall at
Hampton that I just mentioned is an
example where there is there was a
mechanism created to do that if we were
for example to increase the rider uh
cost by another couple of dollars or
another $5 dollar per person to ride
that is a an opportunity to U absorb
some of the costs that can go back into
this and again if you look at you know
the 40-year lifespan of of this project
if it's generating just itself a million
and a half dollars a year um this this
this well it's a large investment
upfront um we should be you know if it's
something that we want to sustain which
I would hope that everybody would think
that if it's something that's been part
of New Hampshire's Legacy for close to a
100 years now that we would like to see
the next version of that uh for our
children for our grandchildren that it
um that we we plan a little further uh
ahead of you know predicting those costs
our new management structure is doing a
lot of work relative to um our Capital
uh needs at ATA at Frank conin and Canon
mountain and and forecasting that out I
I have a lot of faith in what the the
the future holds for us to get out in
front of those things but ultimately all
of our requests come back through here
to to the legislature so we need your
support for there but I think to answer
your question yes there there's some
options for us to offset the cost of
this project or to get it uh um payback
more in some formula through increasing
the cost of uh
visitation I think we're going to close
the uh door on the Canon Mountain
questions for right now I think they've
all
been we're we're all just P facing a
pitiful shortfall at this point in time
so let's move on um to your other items
please thank you
um why don't we keep you here Brian sure
um and we can talk through uh the park
priorities and uh as you can see I the
reason I included the list of 11 items
is just to to give you a sense of how we
the agency organized our priorities it's
a little different than how the governor
um uh organized her Capital priorities
um but but I thought you'd be interested
in in hearing why um we want to maintain
something like a roofing and repairs
fund which is something that we've
worked out with this um uh this
committee over the years so that we're
Nimble and we can react to um all the
fun things that happen at a state park
um with storms and toilets and uh culs
um and so I'll let Brian speak to the
additional priorities behind the Tramway
that are important from the Parks Parks
perspective and then we can talk about
forest and lands sure um well I will
start with the two projects that were uh
put in in the governor's uh Capital
requests uh which were um on bog State
Park uh for some Marina and facility
improvements um there was uh 600 and uh
or I'm sorry
400 looking at the wrong what our
I believe it was like 450 um 475 five
475 475 thank you like price is right
here for a second um 475 uh for um uh
Marina improvements if you're uh not
familiar with AOG State Park we have a
campground and a waterfront uh state
park facility uh that has a a small
modest Marina on the waterfront where we
provide uh both public boat access but
we also uh operate a a uh uh a boat taxi
service to remote campsites that we have
uh located all throughout the lake uh
and and on some islands on the the
middle of Lake it's absolutely
spectacular experience uh up in the umag
wilderness um and the other project that
it was included in the governor's budget
um was $1.5 Million for uh Road repairs
to the Connecticut head uh Connecticut
Lakes Headwaters property uh last bium
we also received 1.5 $5 million um with
that uh so far uh at the end of the 2024
construction season uh we have
resurfaced um about 25 miles of of road
with a gravel top what we were you doing
was um accessing gravel uh from the
property owner uh on site it was being
processed on site and trucked throughout
uh we have over 260 miles of Roads uh
throughout the Connecticut Lakes
Headwaters property that dncr owns and
manages for um Rec primarily for
recreational and public access it also
serves a function for uh logging jobs uh
that occur on that and we work closely
with the property owner on
prioritization of where Road
improvements need to take place um in uh
this past year we've seen uh a number of
uh very significant rainstorms and
flooding events that occurred uh really
throughout the state but on the property
that uh uh continue to uh erode can
compromise certain areas of the road and
our team is working through um upsizing
culverts um working through engineering
and permitting processes there's
actually a few wash outs that are so
large that we won't we likely be going
to put in in a bridge instead of having
a culbert in uh to uh kind of upscale
our re level of resiliency on the
property um so those are the two
projects that are included in the budget
what I will point out is those were our
two lowest priorities within our agency
request
so I'm happy to speak to any of the
other projects in between but the one
that I really think is important uh to
he today is the roofing and repairs fund
uh account that the commissioner
mentioned uh usually on a biannual basis
we're we're usually getting a million
or2 million do uh that is a for
Statewide both the division of forest
lands and the division of parks
infrastructure so that is for uh our our
constant kind of roofing uh and general
repairs we could be painting build
buildings of a large scale at a you know
at a contractor level um they could be
for large SE SE septic failures we've
had trees falling and breaking roofs uh
and other things like that it's usually
mostly for emergent uh circumstances to
keep those facilities open and running
uh septic system failures and and things
of that nature uh this past year we used
a significant portion of that to restore
Northampton State beach after a storm uh
last January basically wiped out half
the entire parking lot um we did get
reimbursement through FEMA for that but
there was no funds available within the
agency to actually respond and repair
for that other than our Roofing and
repairs account so that's where uh the
commissioner mentions us our ability to
be nimble that that is a a really key uh
project for us the last thing I'll do is
just also point out um on here we had a
request for um roads and parking lots
for $4
million um while the Connecticut Lakes
property is is extremely important es
especially for the North country and um
we were able to do a lot last by ANM
with the appropriation that we received
um it it shouldn't go unnoticed that uh
the majority of our Park visitors are
coming to a lot of our parks that are
paved and have uh hardtop parking lots
and other infrastructure with storm
water uh needs and other things um all
of which are in varying degrees of Decay
um and so if I as director I'm looking
at priorities iing you know where is the
biggest need I first think about where
is the biggest amount of visitation and
constituents coming um and what are the
conditions at those facilities um and
have to you know prioritize in in in
that sense so um with
that thank you very much for your
presentation and if you don't mind I
think and I want to float this out for
the uh committee here when we do our
work session on our on this particular
Department would you mind coming back um
so that we can discuss your priorities a
little bit further than what's in the
governor's budget
already yes we can absolutely do that
we'd be happy to thank you um before I
close out our agency can we speak um
briefly about an ongoing project at our
state Nursery Brian you you are
dismissed and I'll call Patrick Hackley
up certainly um so the state Nursery H
have you any of you been it's in bosin
it's a it's a historic site in and of
itself it's um I'll let Patrick get into
the weeds no pun intended Patrick um but
it's it's a it's a revenue generator for
us and it is I believe the oldest
continuously operating
Nursery in in the Northeast in the
Northeast one of the last state
nurseries in the in the region um so my
name is Patrick Hackley I'm the director
for the division of forest and lands um
yeah the the state Nursery in bosin was
uh constructed in
1910 and I don't know how old the cooler
room is but I can tell you that it's
lined with
cork so we've been using that cooler
room to sustain a a $250 to $300,000
business for the state this generates
Revenue that pays for two full-time
staff um uh a Forester and a maintenance
jack of all trades individual who who
does everything from the sprinkler
system to helps with the planting and
sorting and
shipping um it's it's really a wonderful
tradition but it's also a profit Center
for our division we're only about I
would say 28% generally funded um nearly
60% of our funds come from generating
other income and that includes seedlings
at the state Nursery um we have a very
we've had some record years 300,000 is
sort of a record for us last year due to
frost so just like farmers were exposed
to all elements of these crazy Wild
Winters and and hot or dry Summers um we
had that a late May Frost if you all
recall a couple years ago that nipped a
lot of our red oak seedlings um as well
as our Balsam fur which is our our most
popular uh species to sell uh so our
revenues were down last year about 189
to n about
190,000 um but um or orders we sell out
within months of opening our online
store um it's been a very um positive
trend for us the last few years with h
concerns about climate mitigation
there's been a lot of nonprofits buying
seedlings a lot of people getting into
Christmas tree growing that's one of our
biggest clientele we sell seedlings all
over the country but we're one of the
biggest providers of wholesale seedlings
to U uh Christmas tree Growers including
executive counselor wheeler he he buys
our seedlings so um so anyway it's it's
overdue we've um we we replac the
irrigation system last year with arpa
funding it's now a state-of-the-art um
irrigation system system that the
manager can control on his cell phone
with with software uh as needed when
when uh when the seedlings need uh to be
watered so we're we're making these
incremental Capital Improvements and
this next stage is about a 2.5 million
dollar project and we're in the design
we're we're right in the midst or
commencing the design phase right now
which should be completed by early
summer and then the construction phase
should get us into the fall of 20 this
this fall actually it may drip into
2026 but that's that's no the this
that's yeah that's arpa funding but what
we what we're concerned about is in this
next um fiscal year
2627 um in the governor's budget um it
was zeroed out the the force and lands
facilities line up was zeroed out our
concern is that that doesn't leave us
any contingency should the construction
encounter some cost increase or
materials so that that's where you know
we would ask for your consideration and
that we leave something in the in the
tank so to speak for the next fiscal
year if we need to pull from that um we
would get this this Capital Improvement
uh
completed but the 2.5 million is already
we already have the 2.5 but the
preliminary cost estimates from the
contractor place works is on the low end
2.6 on the high end about
2.9 so there's that Delta that we're
concerned about if we don't have uh
anything in that in the following
capital
budget I didn't see anything in the
package with that did I did I miss that
is is it in here we have a brief
narrative in there but it doesn't it it
did not if you could please we can bring
that to the work session this week okay
please
and if there's nothing else first of all
representative Jack how are you with the
laps funds I have looked over and and
I'm pleased to see it's on page one this
time and uh everything uh matches up
with what I have thank you
representative Boyd thank you very much
and just a human interest question
regarding the the Tramway path going up
to the top there's always been an active
bear in there and I'm just curious to
know if it's if it's been uh taken over
this winter
the bear Den I'm looking at our Mountain
manager not to my knowledge yet okay but
we always see those Cubs oh it's the
best it's amazing they Frolic they roll
around it's adorable and when when my
wife and daughter and I we went we were
up there two years ago when we took the
trimite they literally stop and the
driver asked us to be quiet and sure
enough you Mama Bear didn't come up but
the Cubs popped out and it was it's
really the coolest thing so yeah yeah
it's a cool little thing that they got
going on there so it is I I appreciate
that thank you
question thank you all right thank you
very much Mr chair did you have a time
that you wanted the department to come
back next Tuesday I I I don't I don't
know 6. Mr chair I I don't know that
it's going to be next Tuesday I I think
it might be the following week when we
start okay just let us know we're just
going to do the lwh hanging fruit
Tuesday Mr SE just just so you know I
also I also did did the same thing with
the do before they left I told them we
we're going to have them back here and
it might just be the two of them on on
Department of Justice welcome to Public
Works and
highways please
proceed thank you Mr chairman Noti you
notice you have a very short list yes
thank you Mr chairman and good afternoon
members of the committee my name is John
fella I'm the Attorney General at the
Department of Justice and I'm joined
today by David portal he's our director
of Law Office infrastructure we're here
today to present on our capital budget
request which is for a new case
management system for the office as as
we'll talk about our current case
management system is about 20 years old
at this point and it is becoming
obsolete or very soon will be obsolete
so we have a a need for a new system
with that I'm going to turn it over to
David and let him take the laboring ore
on on the presentation here because he
is our our data management and and Tech
whiz at the office but I'll of course be
here to answer any questions and chime
in where needed so with that I'll turn
it over to
David thank you General and thank you
honorable chair and council members for
uh having me here I know your time's
very valuable so let's get down to
business so um my name is David portal I
am the it uh director for the New
Hampshire Department of Justice um I
handle the doj's uh day-to-day
infrastructural and it needs in t with
doit uh we work together on a daily
basis we have uh the wonderful Miss
Rebecca Bolton um from doit here to also
provide support and answers if needed um
I've been in this role for almost two
years and uh one of my main goals uh
since being hired by the doj uh has been
to replace our case management system
which is the impetus for this cap
capital request so um before we go to
Brass tax let me first explain what a
case management system is if we can go
to the next slide um the functions of a
case management system are ostensibly
that they allow law firms and legal
entities to store access and edit files
and information related to cases this
information uh can be case numbers can
be Personnel information outcomes
litigation information as well as actual
documents uh evidence what have you um
case management systems interact with a
Microsoft SQL database um this database
uh is currently being hosted by the
department of it they have expressed to
us that um while they're happy to host
the server they would prefer if we uh
swapped over to a Cloud Server uh
instead just for security reasons um so
uh the case management system uh is the
main file cabinet and the work
environment for doj employees so it's
not just a repository that we dump
documents into for U for posterity it is
uh the first thing that our attorneys
and paralegals open up when they get to
work and it's the last thing that they
close when they clock out um so the case
management system doesn't just include
uh file storage it also includes other
features like timekeeping billing and
Reporting um the Medicaid fraud control
unit grants management unit charitable
trusts unit uh Environmental Protection
Bureau civil Bureau they all make use of
uh this these billing and timekeeping
fun functionalities to um keep track of
how many man hours ostensibly are being
uh spent to support and represent uh
state agencies um and the reporting
functionality is also very important for
our Medicaid fraud control unit and
charitable trust units uh to be able to
generate reports and to meet federal
guidelines um so if you turn to the next
slide I'm going to talk about the doj's
current case management system uh it is
called praw um so praw was uh acquired
by the doj in 2004 so 21 years ago for
$1.2 million adjusting for inflation
that's $2 million today um over the last
20 years the New Hampshire Department of
Justice has paid for various upgrades
pra so it we're not using the version
from 2004 presently we're using the 2020
version um and along the way there's
been multiple upgrades as well uh just
to keep it current um between doit
support uh Personnel licenses and server
Hardware as well as uh our uh
Consultants our contractors that we use
for do for um for praw um the doj spends
roughly $400,000 a year on prw um we
like I said before we do have a
contractor for backend under the hood
support whenever a structural change
needs to be made to prw um and they also
help with day-to-day support and they
help answer questions that we have with
PR so if we turn to the next slide I'm
going to talk about why we need to
replace
PR so uh simply put prola is at the end
of its lifespan um it is it used to be
uh owned by Thompson Reuters but um the
team that works on it has broken off
from Thompson Reuters roughly about a
year ago and they were um they were
purchased by a um by a private Equity
Firm um since then all investment into
pra's development has ceased they're not
putting any more money into prola and
they're also not selling praw to any uh
to any new customers um they're
basically keeping a skeleton crew uh
just on maintenance for praw so u in the
future there could be updates for praw
just for compatibility but but it's not
like it's going to be getting any
feature updates or anything in the
future um so prw lacks a lot of the
features that are Baseline for a lot of
case modern case management systems at
least um and it lacks features like
plain teex searching ecovery tools and
the ability to share cases with outside
Council as well as mobile access which
would be important for victim witness
Advocates um and we could potentially
lose functionality uh for praw within
the year um prolab has add-ins that work
with our Microsoft Office Suite um those
add-ins because Microsoft is sunsetting
um the platform that those add-ins are
on uh could break which would slow down
a lot of the day-to-day work that our
attorneys and paral leals do um and uh
in addition to that it also uh we
recently found out that praw also
doesn't meet uh new federally mandated
performance standards for the Medicaid
fraud control unit um this these
standards basically mean that on the
application side at least prola lacks
the auditing uh features uh automatic
lockout features application Level
encryption features and fire F level uh
encryption features that the feds would
like our Medicaid Brad control unit to
have at least on the application side um
so um moving on sure yeah and just to
add one thing when David says we could
lose some functionality within a year
that doesn't mean of course everything's
just going to stop or we're not going to
be able to operate it just means that
it's going to start to get less than
ideal so it's going to get worse and and
worse right um the only catastrophic um
thing that could happen is that uh Prolo
becomes too old for uh our Microsoft SQL
databases um but there could be upgrades
for that there could not so uh either
way we'd have to pay for those upgrades
um so if we can move to the next slide
it's just a simple summary uh as to the
benefits of replacing prw so uh with
these new modernized tools uh our
attorneys and paralal would achieve uh
increased workflow efficiency um newer
Case Management Systems typically
include built-in workflow management
tools such as inapp messaging and
automated workflow Solutions um which
would help Grease the wheels so to speak
for um for our attorney and and paralal
workflows um we would also achieve
enhanced database security uh a new case
management system would be on the
government Cloud um so doit would no
longer have to worry about maintaining
the security of our database not saying
that the is bad at that they're great at
that but they've expressed to us at
least that uh it would be a better
outcome if if our data were hosted on
the server or on the cloud sorry um and
then finally we could potentially cut
other software from our budget uh we
currently pay for software like everlaw
for ecovery and we also pay for a tool
called perceptive search which basically
lets us conduct a plain Tech search of
our database um we could potentially cut
those pieces of software from our budget
if the new case management tool already
has those features which at least in for
PL Tech searching we know that most new
case management systems have that
feature um if we can move to the next
and final slide we'll discuss the cost
of a new case management system so the
doj estimates uh about a $2.2 million
figure for a completely new uh
cloud-based case management system this
includes initial implementation and
three years of startup support this
would also include a database transfer
of over 20 years of case history so all
the dozens or hundreds of uh terabytes
of case information that we have on our
current database would all have to be
moved over to the cloud which is no
small feat uh the $2.2 million figure uh
comes from a contractor estimate which
also tracks with what we paid for praw
in 2004 as well as what other states
such as uh such as Maine Vermont and
Oregon um project that they'll have to
pay for a new case management system as
well
um now this figure would include the
development and customization of a um of
a new solution uh testing of course uh
cloud storage training uh maintenance
user licenses this should be all
inclusive um this is again consistent
with what other state AG's offices uh
have paid or believe they will pay um
and this would also include the first
two to three years of Maintenance and
data storage as well um now the project
length including the RFP process should
take about three to five years which
also coincides with roughly how long we
believe uh prw will last us at least on
its current version version um that
concludes the
presentation representative Jack thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for coming
uh am I to understand you talk about
other states am I to understand that
every other state is rolling their own
there is nothing off the shelf that uh
you can up that you can migrate to
that's actually a really really good
question so uh currently there is no
Miracle product for a case management
system um I mean there are at least in
the private world you know there's
Solutions like legal files that are very
popular but when it comes to State AG's
offices since our needs are so varied um
from state to state um there's no Sol
solution that just works off the shelf
it's going to require customization it's
going to require uh time from the vendor
to um to to to mold it ostensibly to our
needs representative
Boyd thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question you indicate on
your last page of your uh presentation
that the 2.2 million figure will include
two to three years of Maintenance and
data storage does that also
include um access to a help desk that
would assist you with the software
management and any any other things that
would yes sir that is correct okay
follow up Mr chair follow up in that
regard have you coordinated with the
Department of Information Technology for
when that maintenance agreement is up
that they would be able to step in and
be able to assist you if you had similar
circumstances occur with the technology
moving forward or do you anticipate uh
buying a lack of a better word and
extended warranty on the product to
continue that level of uh maintenance
and help us assess that access that you
need thank you that's a good question so
doit and I have been in lockstep uh on
this project uh we both are are I mean
Rebecca and I meet every every week to
talk about this project for at least an
hour um and from what we understand um
our current our current version of
pra could potentially last us one to two
years it really depends on when those
Comins break and if there's uh if and if
there's no compatibility with a new
version of say Microsoft SQL servers um
but uh we are looking at potentially
upgrading praw to uh the 2024 version
just to get us going for uh for three to
five years while we work on replacing
it okay representative
pal thank you Mr chairman thank takeing
the question how is this going to affect
County attorneys I know our County
attorney mentioned their problem I mean
and also with CMS so how do you think
this will affect County Attorney's
Office including like Hillsboro County
which is biggest right uh we don't use
the the I'm sure you know this but uh we
don't use the same system as the County
attorneys so I mean us updating our case
management system shouldn't directly
affect them um but if if the new case
management system is robust enough uh it
could help Grease the wheel in terms of
uh getting information and getting uh
Case Files uh to and from these County
attorneys and the Department of Justice
faster repres representative bogert I
pass representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
along those same lines we're currently
updating our system it system in Carol
County as well so has there been in any
interaction with the county attorney's
office about what would be compatible
with the systems that you're planning to
move forward forward with because I know
we're we have to do it because of the
cloud and the windows issues that are
dying basically in November of this year
so has that been ongoing so we make sure
that maybe the county attorney's office
would be able to do something that was
more effective and more compatible with
you since I my understand is I do work
with you on a regular basis right uh
thank you for the question so um we
haven't spoken we haven't coordinated
with county attorney's offices yet but
they will definitely be a part of the
process to ensure that all on the same
level I know the county attorney's
offices like to use prosecutor by carpel
there could be a world where we end up
on prosecutor by carpel and that would
make things um easier for the doj to
coordinate with the county attorney's
offices but um obviously it's going to
have to go out to bid so I I ideally
we're on the same system but it could be
another case where we're on two separate
systems and hopefully if they use at
least the same Baseline document
management system such as Salesforce
then uh it could help our workflow
significantly just so you know they'll
probably be contacting you thank you
look forward to it and and just to
supplement yes apologies Mr chair just
to supplement that briefly it's
important to to note and remember that
what we do is a lot broader than what
the county attorney's offices do so we
do just a lot of things they don't do so
that's another challenge in having say
maybe the exact same system but as much
compatibility as we can have we agree
the better and and the final question is
going to representative Newman yes thank
you it's it's a it's a three-parter but
I'll roll it into one because I'm clever
okay the um other states and I I'll just
get it out and you can answer other
states use prola now um that's a
question and the doj estimate of 2.2
million is that a a hard estimate or is
it a to be adjusted maybe depending
on the way things go and that is um tied
in with new federally mandated
performance standards are those also a
moving Target right now possibly to deal
with as you go along so to answer your
first question um so not every other
state AG's offices uses PR law uh
there's a few Hawaii uses PR law Nevada
uses PR law California uses PR law but
um from what I understand uh all the
state AG's offices are all using mostly
different solutions and of them can
agree on one that's perfect it molds to
to the needs of the AG's office in
question um I'm sorry remind me of your
second question the doj estimate of 2.2
million is that a firm number so it's
this is just what sorry this is just
what one contractor gave us and again
it's it's in line with what we paid in
2004 it could be more it could be less
based on the bids that we get we're
going to put out an RFP so we're going
to get hopefully a lot of bids um but
but this could there we could be in a
world where you know we we get a bid for
1.5 million and that would be great and
if that met all of our business
requirements and that would be perfect
but we also don't want to be in a
position where we go with a um a
solution that's a fraction of that $2.2
million figure and it also only meets a
fraction of our business requirements as
theyr yes from what I understand they're
set in concrete they're um on their
fed's website um they obviously can
change as they did for us but it's it I
don't necessarily know the frequency at
change gentlemen thank you very much for
you and we're getting back on schedule
next up and I'm with sorry for the delay
we
welcome to public works thank you uh and
and you look by far you look like the uh
the happiest people that that we have so
far you you only had seven requests you
got five of them I mean everybody is is
going to be envious of yes yes they're
small money but important life changes
for our veterans um I'll go ahead and
start uh we gave you a powerpoint
presentation just a little bit about a
history the projects we currently have
and the ones that we requested um so in
the New Hampshire Veterans Home in 1890
took advantage of some federal
assistance with Governor Goodell um and
established a board of managers made up
of prominent citizens the facility
opened its doors the first time for
Civil War soldiers unable to care for
themselves on December 3rd 1890 so we
just celebrated uh 35 years in December
from the first day um in the 134 or 35
years there's been 11 commod Dons that
have held the position I'm in right now
so it's a traditional very prideful
honorable um position in facility we are
unique in that we're ran by the board of
managers they oversee our operations the
board is made up of 12 members who are
appointed by the governor and confirmed
by the executive Council the commanders
for the American Legion the Veterans of
Foreign uh Wars and disabled American
veterans and nine citizens make up our
Board of managers two of the 12 members
of our Board of managers are actual
residents that live with us one male one
female so they're representing their
voice in our meetings the board has
oversight of the veterans benefit fund
operations as well as appoints the
commant today we are a long-term
Intermediate Care Facility so some
nursing homes have ICF uh beds
intermittent Care Facility or skilled
beds we are only ICF we only take uh
people who meet long-term
criteria uh we offer uh Medical Services
nursing services and only to Veterans uh
we have licens for
250 beds we are funded by uh the um
state for
225 and recently I think most medical
professionals will tell you the the most
difficult part right now is Rec
recruitment and retaining of medical
staff nurses
especially we are we utilize the veteran
affairs VA Grant that enables us um to
receive a majority of our payments um
and we are we are uh surveyed annually
it's usually in April I say that because
last year was the first time they had
missed the mark and we hit May uh but
they go through a survey process and
certify us to provide services through
through the VA and uh eligible for
reimburse that's important because
that's why we have some of our life
safety things here the mission of the
New Hampshire Veterans Home is to
provide the provide the best quality of
life for New Hampshire veterans with
dignity honor and respect and I feel
very confident that our staff do that so
yes we are Smiley we are happy we work
in a great place so we're very proud of
that um infrastructure we're looking at
veterans uh health and life safety
measures we always look at that they
come in and do a survey we also have
local survey uh look at our systems to
make sure we're meeting all of the life
safety Health life safety requirements
we also must meet ADA requirements which
is one of the budget um capital budget
projects that did not get funded uh and
we mentioned that as far as redoing one
of our units the doors are too narrow uh
showers are not meeting ADA requirements
we also must meet in uh affection and
prevention controls as we saw with the
uh covid outbreak it can be devastating
in any kind of longterm care or congrate
living and we must meet those VA law
requirements in the survey requirements
to continue to be able to serve the
veterans re get that reimbursement from
the VA and stay
licensed uh the status of our current
projects we had F we have five current
projects going on one is the state W
sitewide drainage and water life safety
Improvement project um in parts of our
building when the rain comes or the snow
melts it comes in our basement and so we
are working on that that is underway to
try to divert some of that water and
elsewhere we have entry life um life
safety improvements we have no canopies
or no covers over many of our doorways
so again with the ice and the and the
snow coming off those roofs it becomes
very dangerous and we have to close some
of our entrances so this will address
that bidding will be posted on March
25th 2025
medical lift installation you will see
that on our um budget request again and
we call it phase three this time but
phase two uh these are lifts that are in
uh inputed into our ceiling to help us
move safely the veterans um that cannot
help themselves so uh it is for their
life safety but also to prevent injury
to our staff to help move uh veterans uh
throughout their room area and then we
have the Veterans Home Building Edition
which was originally called the Leo Life
Enhancement dementia unit Edition um uh
years ago they were planning to build a
third floor and uh the government uh the
VA approved the project with the state
so the VA pays 65% the state has to pay
35 um we have had that money encumbered
uh in 2022 we finally got the go from
the VA to go ahead and move forward with
that project and um we went we developed
a a site it could not be on the third
floor there were no no longer was that
enough money to actually support a third
floor addition and I believe the quality
of life of a third floor addition would
not be the same as a ground floor so we
identified area on our facility campus
that we could actually um connect our
buildings and uh build a first floor
with enclosed Courtyards and that those
will be 20 beds with 20 private
bathrooms I think our veterans deserve
not to live with two people in one room
two in another and all four of them
using a bathroom we also know that that
infection prevention um is such a bad
practice it will spread any kind of
illness whether it's a covid or a flu or
any of those other uh illnesses so that
project is underway we went out to bid
the first time and we got one bid but we
were only 30% design and most people
wanted to see more design so they could
make a a educated decision about a bid
so we actually complet completed a 100%
design we went out to bid last month or
we opened bids last month and we had
five um biders and uh it looks really
good I think we're going to definitely
meet the Target and move forward with
that we have been reassured as of
yesterday I just wanted to update just
in case um the VA it is called a
construction Grant so I have verified
with the VA that that is not at risk uh
with the current um cuts that are being
made to the um to the federal government
so that that money is still there and
has been reassured to us and then the
last project that's uh ongoing is the
parking lot repair and expansion is 80%
done we hope to have it done by July 1
but our luck has not been so great so we
have asked to bring that forward again
we uh have just some striping to do in
the parking lot and we also have uh a
little bit of um Courtyard work so uh
we're looking forward to that
um I was a miss too I'm sorry I just
wanted to introduce by my side here is
Brian Baker he's our chief of operations
and he has the most years experience
sitting at this table within the VA uh
within the New Hampshire veterans home
he's been there for 20 plus years so uh
he will be able to answer any detailed
questions um for our Governor's funded
projects this year we have on here this
list uh replace three Air Handlers the
diesel tank replacement replace seven
veteran tubs um and and purchase a
bariatric stretcher trolley replace 50
beds and 20 medical lifts phase three so
on page nine we think the best thing to
do is show you photos and show you
what's happening up there the air
handlers units serve uh three resident
neighborhoods with over a 100 Veterans
living in them they're now 30 years old
with deteriorating parts and due to
their age the units are Obsolete and
can't be rep reped in attempt last
summer during the hot time we got uh we
did have a welder come in and make some
repairs and try to limp it along um but
they only lasted about a month because
it's welded and it's just moving
constantly so due to last lack of
Integrity in the metal Parts when these
units start to shake they violently
cause cracks and breaks and you'll see
some of those in the photos that we've
given you here um on page N9 and 10 so
we definitely need to address those when
those um no longer work we will lose
heating and air conditioning um and that
would be devastating to our population
at this
point the second um priority that was
granted by the governor um is and for
your consideration is the underground
diesel tank replacement and I know we
heard some questions about that we have
about a 12,000 gallon diesel tank um
buried on our property and it's the
distance of the fuel that it it goes is
about 100 plus feet how how long does it
the distance it's about 300t 300 ft it
has to travel it used to um have the
fuel for all of our generation
generators but we went to and what and
boilers but we went to natural gas so
there's one small generator that still
lives off this um Berry diesel tank and
uh we need to empty out the diesel
because diesel has a life and we're
getting to the ended that life
expectancy and then we have to remove
the tank and put a new tank closer to
the line and um be able to uh generate
that uh generator so uh we're asking for
a money $60,000 again to take that tank
out of the ground replace it um a
different location and replace it with a
much smaller tank which we will able to
use that money that that um diesel in a
much quicker way because we use it for
testing hopefully we don't really have
have to use
it uh replace seven uh seven tubs we
have tub rooms and these are this is an
example of a tub that is used uh they're
critical to provide care for our
veterans they're critical and what's
been happening is they've all aged out
and the company's not making them or
supporting them so what we've started to
do is on units that we don't have uh
residents we are actually pirating off
those parts and rep putting putting them
on the other tubs to to try to limp them
along um it we're in dire need of of
replacing the tubs um obviously that's a
a quality of life that can't be avoided
we need to be able to B the veterans and
then we are wanted to purchase one
bariatric stretcher trolley which on
page 13 shows you a picture of that and
it will allow us to be the residents
that um that need the bariatric care in
a much safer way these tubs even the
bariatric ones are often not big enough
for uh a true bariatric resident so we
well replace 50 resident beds um these
are the actual beds often what we think
of like a hospital bed um our beds are
so old that they have a knee Locking
System where you actually use your knee
to push the lock on um instead of a foot
break and so what's happening is people
are using their knees to lock this and
there's a lot of iny that happens um
some have to it's so hard to do it
they're actually using their bodies to
try their hands to try to lock them we
need to replace these uh and again this
will be the similar approach I would
have is to do that in phases so we can
phase out the most
uh the the worst beds I guess I would
say um and put the need where they need
and then make sure we're never asking
for too much we'll do phasing it all in
um the goal is to replace them each uh
each bium uh the VA requires us to
annually test our beds and ensure that
they're in good working order and we've
had to take some out just because of age
the wires are not good the plugs are not
good they're just not healthy so we
definitely need uh the bed
Replacements we are also asking for
phase three of these medical lifts and
this is an example of that
lift right now when somebody is coming
into our facility if a veteran is going
to be emitted and has um a need to be
lifted uh they can't they need a
two-person lift um we have to place them
within our facility according to where
we have lifts not where the best
programming may be for them but we have
to look at where do we have lifts that
we can actually move them safely or we
have to use portable lifts which are um
inherently not the best way to do that
you can have a lot of uh you know
accidents with a portable lift so this
is phase two uh phase three uh right now
we have 38 rooms would lifts and we have
four bathrooms but we would like to
increase that number and not have to
make a room decision based on where
veteran so uh slide 16 is again just the
what we're looking at um we hope that
the water drainage uh life safety will
be done by the Summer
2005 we're hoping the entry will
actually be done before uh June 30 but
we just don't know that so we're
actually leaving that on for summer 2025
we're asking to bring all projects
forward uh the the addition is well
underway we're hoping that uh we'll be
breaking ground this summer with a year
and a half um they say a year but my
experience with any kind of construction
is at six months so we're realistically
thinking a year and a half and then the
parking lot upgrades um we're we're so
close to being done we're hoping that
will be done as well as this summer um
so we're have a tradition of providing
the best care uh to the veterans of the
State of New Hampshire we're really
proud of that um and with your support
we hope to continue um representative
Jack for uh thank you if I understood
you correctly we're not bringing forward
the medical Phase 2 because that's
complete it's complete sir uh do we know
if there's any balance left in that
account I believe it was uh under $200
okay we are Yankees representative Boyd
thank you Mr chairman comment on thank
you for taking my question you are the
third agency that is before us that is
looking to replace an underground diesel
tank so I get to ask my question for the
third time okay and we did hear it so
okay so if you've heard the question can
you answer the qu actually for the for
the for the people watching at home is
it possible for the tank to be either
filled with cement or sand and then cap
to avoid removing the tank so I did I
made the call to the EPA to to ask that
very question question and they inform
me that the new guidelines they don't
allow it so it has to be removed so the
old way of doing it was we'd scrub it
with a detergent fill it with concrete
they do not allow that anymore unless
there is a extenuating circumstance
where you cannot get to it but ours is
kind of open so we really don't fit that
mold okay ask and answer thank you well
I have a little followup on it because I
having been on this committee for so
long and seeing some of these things
over and over and over again this isn't
the first time we've talked about this
tank is it it is not didn't didn't we
move it once before did it did it get
scrubbed from your project list we moved
it because we were looking at trying to
upgrade our generator to natural gas
because we have natural gas so we moved
this once before so you could put more
generators in so now we're going to
remove it because you got rid of
generators well no so we weren't able to
so we the supplier would not allow us to
add more um units to the natural gas
supply so now we're back to sticking
with diesel
for that
um what phase are we on we're on phase
three for your medical lift
installations how many more
phases um well with the addition that
we're going to be building there's going
to be 20 lifts we put that in that
addition we're not we ask for that right
away so with that 20 and the 42 we
already have and if you gave us 20 more
we'd be probably looking at on honestly
if I'm being truthful I'd probably back
one more time to ask for another phase
of it because we want the majority of
the beds to be covered and we have 250
beds you're to be you're to be commended
you guys always come in here in little
increments and stuff that's why I I keep
looking at the same stuff every two
years going okay and I believe I was
asked last year are you going to come
back every year every two years and I
said yes I would for a while there's
small I mean our overall ask is very
small but they're big projects to us in
our smaller budget representa bone thank
you Mr chairman and thank you I've been
to your facility some years ago as a
member of the New Hampshire Patriot God
excellent and you do a great job and I
just want to come in thank you so much
thank you representa boy I'm I'm sorry
represent bogur thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question um this
is actually a followup to the Chairman's
question uh the 20 that you want to do
in phase three those are
for
existing areas and as the second part of
that question in your new section that
you're
building if you need medical lifts that
was put into the cost of the new
building so that should be not included
in this 20 yes sir so the uh 20 that
we're talking about would go into
existing rooms in um what we call our
downstairs uh neighborhood there's 100
there so we have no lifts down there
we're using portable lifts so we would
be putting those 20 down there the new
addition which we have not named yet um
but that will have 20 beds and one of
the things that we put in right away is
that we needed 20 lifts in every room
nine of those rooms will actually be
bariatric lifts they will be able to
sustain um up to 1,000 pounds so we are
really like looking into the future
saying not only do we need the standard
lifts we need some bariatric rooms The
Wider
doors and just one followup uh and those
were included in the cost of the already
yes that that's part of the project I
will not be coming to ask for beds in uh
lifts in the
area any further
questions yes representative
chair and and thanks for responding to
my question there was one item or one of
the items uh that are not being covered
now that you have listed had to do with
the South uh Ada and safety upgrades and
reading the uh you know what they are um
you really need them to sound like some
of them were safety things that you
should have yes so we we basically the
that that neighborhood uh our group of
neighborhoods we've actually moved
residents off that neighborhood it's not
safe for them to be on their floors
tiles popping up uh there some rooms the
doors are wider than others uh if you
looked at Armor or closet space they're
broken it's the it's in really really
bad repair um and so we have moved
everybody off those units and we're not
using them and it is a big ticket item I
think it was 1.5 million um we put it on
there with the fingers crossed hoping it
would get through um but it I would be
happy to share uh photos with you I can
even send them to you if for your next
meeting if you'd like but that area we
cannot use that whole area um if we had
to use that it I think that we would
have problems with our VA survey and our
life safety
surveys okay thank you thank you thank
you Mr just just as a followup to that
um I said listened to so many of these
requests over the years what was the
status you had you had part of your
addition a new addition put on and then
a couple years ago there was all the
electrical cable problems or something
like that am I remembering that
correctly we had to go in and rewire
things was that ever we haven't had an
addition since uh 20 years right 203
2003 was our last Edition so we had then
there was repairs to that one was there
repairs to that so we yeah we've done
I've been there since 2001 we've done
several repairs to uh the roof firewalls
uh electricals been upgraded we we've
done a lot I I always asked because back
then I was still working i' had retired
and work work part-time and help build
all your Cabinetry and all your woodwork
when they remodel that thing so I've
always tried to follow up on oh what was
that who who was doing all that shoty
work in there wasn't me I was only an
apprentice
okay representative Boyd thank you Mr
chairman very quickly H how many beds
right now are at the home how many vets
are occupying those beds and how many
vacancies and what are there
possibilities with some of the work that
we're talking about that will be adding
more beds to the facility yes so as I
said we are uh budgeted for
225 um so I have to match the amount of
vacancies that I have with nursing
positions specifically with how many
veterans I can bring in um so we we have
aund right now we have 135 veterans 125
men and 10 women we have planned uh a
few more admissions are already planned
and we have about 40 veterans that are
in the process of being uh applying for
our services so we know we could get
there we could easily fill 175 beds if I
had the staff to do that so it's a
balancing that I have to do with making
sure the quality of care is there we're
meeting their needs and right now I have
a a nursing vacancy rate of
37% with an LNA vacancy licensed nursing
assistant of
44% and so with those vacancies uh it
makes it difficult to go all the way up
and we know that we are um not meeting
the needs of all the community veterans
that could come in which is the hard
thing that we balance so when we have
Admissions and we look at who's coming
in the door next we are always waiting
that with a risk so we never do it in a
deli style where someone's in line and
they're number one or two or three we
look at the weight list that's currently
there and say who is at home at most
risk or where are they that has the most
risk and we admit from that from that
perspective right now we are in the
process of next week um moving some beds
around to use utilize our staff in the
best way and our plan is to go to 150
residents with our current Staffing that
we have we feel that we could safely do
that with the reorganization of how
we're uh housing the different
neighborhoods um so our goal is 15 today
with that sensus or with that uh vacancy
rate but our bigger goal is to hit that
225 we need to make sure uh we can get
all of those veterans in and I think
that 175 is easy I think that the easier
part would be to get the additional we
have to know we have to let all the
veterans in the community know that you
can come to us quickly because right now
they don't feel like they can come to us
quickly if there's a need and then
someone's hospitalized they often go to
another facility and then come back to
us from another facility we'd like to be
that quick turnaround you need us we're
there we're going to able to serve you
but you underline the point that the
continuity of care pce is absolutely
necessary in order for for the veterans
to get the the quality of kid that they
need and deserve y absolutely thank you
comedon thank you thank you final
question representative Brown thank you
Mr chairman so do you currently use
agency Staffing like most of the other
counties and you still can't get enough
Staffing we are using agency staff you
can get more but it costs a lot of money
so you have to weigh that is it worth as
tax dollars and the state taxpayer money
to increase by one or two veterans um
and then how reliable is that because
they often go to another contract they
stay for 13 weeks um and if I sta if I
bring in uh the veterans and I don't
have the staff to provide the care so
again we're always looking at that
really we use most of our Staffing
temporary staffing contract is Staffing
on second shift hardest shift to fill uh
because some people are just shift night
owls and most people like to work days
so it's that second shift that we have
the most difficulty and that's where we
use the contracts thank you very much
thank you thank you very much for your
you I'm
did some of those some of those some of
those facades when you first walk in are
one piece it to it took like 12 of us to
hold it up put it against the ceiling I
I know what the guys that that hang
gutters feel like now oh yeah I was
you an extra copy of Sarah
Stewart's remarks no okay fair enough
natural next up we're looking for
UNH
please welcome to public
works good afternoon and thank you
thanks for having us this
afternoon and I apologize I didn't get
everyone's name on the agenda so folks
can introduce themselves so my name is
Katherine prenter I serve as the
chancellor of our states University
system and um very much appreciate your
time this afternoon like to walk you
through some information about our
capital budget and our capital budget
request with me is Adam Kohler from um
the University of New Hampshire
facilities department and Natalie howder
Keen State Vice President of Finance and
I'm going to pinch hint for for Plymouth
state
so um we'll walk you through some slides
I think um cret also has the electronic
version um but also obviously we have
hard copies for you this
afternoon so um in accordance with
statute University system submitted a
six-year capital budget as has been the
case in the past three bium the the
legislature adopted a three banian
budget for the University system so
there were 21 2021 22 23 24 25 if I have
that right um we requested that of the
governor she decided not to put that in
in her budget the 3 by enum request um
however we are very um appreciative the
governor did include the entire 20
million that we requested for fiscal
years 26 and 27 and we'll walk you
through that um this
afternoon the um and these $20 million
has significant impact obviously on our
entire capital budget and I'll talk a
little bit about that in a minute so um
if you go to slide
three you'll see that
um there are projects in this capital
budget request that are
continuations of current capital
projects that are that are ongoing
primarily hide Hall at
Plymouth um we have requested in fiscal
Year's 26 27 4 million for Plymouth 4
million for Kean and 12 million for
UNH but we're seeking to revise that
allocation of request because in the
last bium the language was so flexible
enough that we accelerated Hyde Hall at
Plymouth because of its impact and
because of its cost so in this current
bium there were more State dollars put
toward hide than was originally
anticipated
so on slide four I just want to take a a
moment to tell talk a little bit more
about the entire Capital program across
the university
system University system spends about 65
to70 million per year on our Capital
program um we have 9.2 million grow
square feet across all our campuses we
have you know basically three little
towns or cities that we're running um
428 buildings that doesn't include steam
lines that we have roads we maintain
water facilities energy generation so we
have quite a significant Capital
operation if you will across Plymouth
State Keane State and the University of
New
Hampshire and you'll see in that pie
chart and this this comes from our
audited financial statements and this is
5 years worth of total Capital spend
about half of the capital spend that the
university system incurs comes from what
we call education and general funds so
that would be tuition Revenue possibly
research revenue we do issue debt we can
only issue debt for
self-supporting facilities so by that I
mean dorms dining Halls student unions
Rec calls any academic space we do not
have the authority to issue debt for in
in statute and so the state has been an
incredible partner in helping with that
academic space right to for educational
purposes Workforce all of that um
auxiliary as I mentioned the auxiliary
funds are room and board so those fees
help fund those facilities and the
capital Appropriations again have been
15% a meaningful percentage of our
overall Capital program over the last
five
years on uh Slide
Five again I mentioned the the
partnership the university system has
enjoyed has been really impactful I
mentioned earlier um we'd like to move
some of the allocation between Plymouth
and Keane that was in the request that
we did a year ago I should mention I
probably should have led with this um
enrollment is declining we have
significant headwinds it's a fact in
higher ed especially in New England but
in many parts of the country so we are
undergoing pretty significant plans on
evaluating the footprint what does the
footprint need to look like a decade
from now we've been selling space we've
demolished um dorms at Keen we H are
exiting least space we so we are in the
process of evaluating the facil how
we're sharing space we have um the River
Valley Community College is occupying
space at Keen State College the system
my system office University system
office is moving to the nhti campus in a
few months so we're really trying to
think about space in the future we won't
need all this space and how will the
space look like that we will have and so
when we put this capital budget together
a year
ago the the totals doesn't change but
we'd like to allocate more to Kean less
to Plymouth because we spent more on
Plymouth in this bium to accelerate that
hide Hall project because of the impact
frankly it's going to have on the Lakes
Region and the North
Country so what I'd like to do now Adam
and Natalie are going to walk through
some of the details of the projects that
um at UNH and keen and I'll talk about
the hide Hall project unless there are
questions before they get into any any
other
um
material I just have one question so you
were talking you've got four million
each for uh hiy Hall and four for Keem
State Elliot Center so out of that 8
million you just want to reallocate that
back and forth correct do do you have
any numbers in mind yes if you go if
you're on on um slide three yeah if you
go to the column The Columns just to the
um right of the governor's recommended
and I've included usnh at revised oh
okay so it'd be a million at hide and
actually and Natalie's going to talk
about this in a minute we're not even
going to do Elliott we're going to put
Elliot aside even though there's
significant um deferred maintenance we
think those dollars could be better
spent at Morrison Redfern and Ketty and
there's M again a little more material
in in the deck so that's where we'd like
okay um move
to okay thank you proceed okay there you
go good afternoon chairman Mills and
members of the committee um it's my uh
pleasure to be here with you today to
tell you a little bit about our Morse
Hall renovation uh Morse Hall is home to
the Institute of the um study of Earth
oceans and space commonly known as EOS
we love our acronyms and that's one gets
thrown around a lot so Morse Hall was
constructed in 1986 it's named after
Richard A Morse class of 1951 and a
long-standing member of the um usnh
Board of
Trustees it's really a Cornerstone
building on the UNH campus kind of quite
literally sits on a on a corner street
um it's a significant building in four
stories 130,000 Square ft of overall
space if you haven't been there one of
the uh notable things about Morse Hall
is the atrium that runs right through
the core of the building has skylights
that let Natural Light Flow down through
and and um certainly a unique space on
campus so Morse Hall is primarily a
research and teaching lab building along
with faculty support support
space and in uh researching to prepare
today I found that the teaching mission
of EOS um resonated with me and I wanted
to tell you read that that to you so the
the mission of EOS is to educate
outstanding students capable of
advancing our understanding of the earth
and its setting in the universe I just
thought that was kind of a nice uh nice
statement um so
the our project at Morse Hall consists
primarily of a of a building wide HVAC
replacement project as I mentioned the
building was constructed in 1986 and all
the mechanical systems are original to
the building ofth than you know minor ad
hoc uh modifications and repairs over
the years so it's a complete replacement
of the air
systems um includes modernizing the Fume
hoods which are necessary for safety but
also to manage energy use as you can see
on a little infographic we included mors
Hall has 19 Fume hoods and each one of
those hoods uh consumes annually about
the same amount of energy as a as a
typical home so they consume a lot of
energy but are are required for research
and for safety of our our faculty and
staff um as part of the project not only
are we replacing Mechanicals but we're
also uh making repairs and improvements
to the thermal envelope uh including
sealing up the windows and reducing the
space um so as I mentioned the the
systems are closing in on 40 years old
the the picture that we included you
know shows that they're not in great
shape but almost doesn't do it justice
really we're at the end of useful life
so one of the things about EOS and the
type of research that they do is that it
requires really um tight tolerances for
space temperature and humidity in the
space and the mechanical systems really
you know are past past being usable for
even maintaining basic you know Heating
and Cooling comfort and just not up to
the task for for maintaining the
humidity and temperature tolerances that
we need in mors Hall which are a
requirement of the grants that the
researchers there um
procure um and then as I mentioned the
uh infiltration just exacerbates that
because when we have leakage coming
through the windows it makes it that
much harder to manage the the humidity
temperature so moving on to the funding
picture um we're projecting uh uh
overall project cost of 22.5 to $24.9
million currently uh a little bit of a
range as we continue to wrap up uh the
uh construction uh documents
um and we are projecting funding that
with 1.5 to $3.9 million in usnh gifts
and funds and then have two uh State
funding requests one for the current
banm and one projected for uh the
subsequent
um I talked a lot about EOS because they
are the main occupant of the Morse hall
building um really notable on the UNH
campus in that they're currently
responsible for 40 to 50% of the overall
research dollars coming into the
university that's an annual average of
about $60 million but in recent years
through some really significant grants
that's gone as high as a $100 million in
FY
23 nearly every member of the research
faculty in mors Hall is funded through
grants and they secure over 100 grants
basis with
that any I'll move into Plymouth unless
anyone has questions I'm sorry we do
have questions representative
Boyd thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I appreciate it and I
apologize I I missed your
name your name my name is Kathy
preventure thank you oh geez I apologize
my neighbor no no need to apologize I
apologize I apologize m m Miss
preventure alluded to the fact that
self-sustaining abilities facilities
have the ability to bond themselves I
also know that UNH has been um alumni
have been very grateful with their
donations to the university so like my
question is is what's to prevent the
University from using some of their
endowment money or using using some of
their bonding money to uh to subsidize a
project as as uh as intensive as
repairing
morsa so thank you for the question
representative um the university has
used actually bonding money and gift
money on other recent projects so um
hetel
Hall uh we issued debt for that that's a
residence hall that had been shuttered
and um we recently changed requirements
of freshmen and sophomores live on
campus so hetel Hall which is right in
the heart of Campus we blonded for that
we've also recently received um generous
gifts the Hamill Honors College that was
funded by um generous ster so that those
dollars are there um I I don't believe
that Morse would um I don't think we
could bond for that because we don't
charge a fee see we the our our bonds
are backed by the fee Revenue that we
charge for a dorm or a dining hall and
we don't charge a fee for the use of the
academic space we don't we don't issue
General obligation bonds like the state
does backed by the full faith and credit
of the University system if that makes
sense we issue bonds that are only
backed by the revenue stream that comes
from the fee on those buildings um
representative if if we had a generous
donor that would fund this project by
um no I know I just I appreciate you
answering my question um thank you do we
want to keep asking questions now or do
we want to let them finish their
questions individually okay better thank
you all right representative Boger yeah
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question my question is on
page 10 of your uh you said 40 or 50 40
to 50% of all research revenue uh is
generated by this one building and grant
funding uh equals $100
million uh how much of that 100 million
is
private grants versus public grants
thank you for the question
representative the vast majority of our
grants are federal grants I think it's
about 75% of our grants are federal
grants most are not private follow up
please follow
up with that being said in uh
uh and in looking at this Revenue
Source uh for the building do we
anticipate that being uh remaining in a
positive
manner in the near future
in thank you for the question
um there's a lot of uncertainty
obviously there's a lot of uncertainty
right now um UNH is one of only I think
14 institutions in our country that are
land sea and space
grants um for for for a university of
its size it's
actually quite a little Powerhouse in in
research it's an R1 which is a the top
research classification that said there
is real uncertainty about federal grants
what is going to flow um and we are
monitoring that
closely as of the 28th of February we
had received notification from the
Social Security Administration that
there were three grants totaling
$700,000 where there would be there was
a stop work order so that funding is
going to cease um again we
are if the grant dollars don't
flow there will
be a number of people that will be laid
off I don't I just there's a lot of
uncertainty I don't think that it's
going to we don't anticipate that it's
going to completely dry up to
zero and again this
space space maybe that this
building is more than half of all the
research so I I am we are confident that
it will might not continue at the level
it's flowing right now but I remain
confident it will continue to to um
there will continue to be research
done representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman so this is
kind of a two-part question just
answered part of it but I want to make
sure I'm correct on it so this Morse
Building is primarily a re resarch
facility it doesn't support degrees oh
oh go ahead I was going to say it it it
is primarily research but there are
there is classroom space and it does
support a lot of um there's a lot of
student participation in the building um
so EOS is multidisciplinary it doesn't
belong with any one qual uh one college
at the
University um but I believe that uh the
the latest numbers I heard was was that
there are um you know over 300 uh
undergraduate students who utilize uh
Morse Hall on a on an annual basis so
along that same line so what type of
degrees does this support just
curious sure um
so
um the so there is a lot of uh Masters
and PhD research that goes on within the
umbrella of um EOS so it is a lot
related to Ocean engineering um
Aerospace and that type of of um you
know seps type degrees but then also
does with the multidisciplinary crosses
over to um KSA our College of um life
sciences and agriculture as well okay so
just a kind of F this thank you Mr
chairman so you're looking to I'm not
used to people asking to change use of
money when they already Justified the
money for something else so my question
is is there a breakdown anywhere as to
what the changes are and why these
changes are a prior for you now as
opposed to what you had asked for
previously um absolutely thank you
representative um so none of the changes
are for
Morse and I am ha I'm happy to follow up
on a couple things now from listening
give you give you more detail on the
Hyde Elliot Morrison because remember we
put these together over a year ago um
and we in higher red are in a rapidly
changing environment um Madam Chancellor
why don't why don't we hold off on this
question then until we cover those two
parts I caught that right away that's
why I said let's hold off on some of
these questions until they have a chance
to go ahead and present why they're
doing this thanks Mr chairman I'd like
to follow up though I want to come back
um to the committee with more
information on the degrees and
programs being being worked on in Morris
because I can tell you another while we
say you it's primarily research being
done in moris the University of New
Hampshire Prides itself on embedding
even undergrad students in the research
so when research is being conducted it's
there are students side by side um in
that research space so I'd like to get
you some more detail on the programs and
the degrees that are being worked on
okay repr of jur thank you Mr chairman
for the Mechanicals at uh at Morse Hall
are they being fueled by the Steam
Plant Morse Hall is connected to our
district Energy System so it's actually
getting um District heating hot water
from the plant rather than steam um but
it is connected to the overall campus
utility networks it also is connected to
our district uh chilled water
infrastructure and is served by the new
thermal energy storage tank that was
just constructed on campus so it's
really you know it is uh entirely
powered uh and heated and cooled from
the University uh District systems okay
thank you thank you for the question
let's go ahead and proceed with the rest
your presentation please sure thank you
and so um Hyde Hall at
Plymouth discussion about that project
starts on on slide 12 mentioned earlier
it's the um 81,000 growth square feet
the most used academic space on the
Plymouth State campus um I want to say
six or eight years ago um the the
president at Plymouth went to what's
called a cluster learning model so all
majors now are work on projects with
other major so interdisciplinary teams
are working and so the the hide Hall is
the home of the Innovation and
Entrepreneurship cluster and those those
um students and faculty work hand inand
with businesses governments nonprofits
in the lakes and North Country region on
projects um trying to innovate and help
with
entrepreneurship the
um this the condition of hide was
frankly it was abysmal
before the university system was
fortunate enough to see um State support
on that building that the construction
on that building has been ongoing I
think for six years um and it's almost
finished and we actually accelerated
construction on that building because we
recognized that it will have real impact
on the North Country getting students
and and connected with businesses and
faculty um and so that's why and and I
could talk to Chris about this offline
in the last capital budget the way that
was worded it provided the university
system flexibility so there was a total
appropriated and then there was another
section that said hidde Hall UNH
Spalding Hall Kean Elliott and it didn't
put the dollars specific to the project
if that makes any sense and so and it
gives um and in the in hb25 the same
thing it gives our board some
flexibility on these projects will be
done accordance with Board of Trustees
policies and so we accelerated that High
um project and slow down any work on
Elliot at Keen because we continue to
re-evaluate
um where where we have to put the
limited dollar that we have for Capital
so you'll see on slide
13 we're seeking a million dollars for
hide in the upcoming bium 2627 to finish
the project
off and Natalie will talk about the
shift from Elliott to Morrison and
frankly most of it at Keen is um life
safety deferred maintenance on on
buildings that have a lot use on the
campus and again we have so many dollars
to spend and so we're trying to Pivot as
we continue to analyze our footprint and
um where we need to to put our dollars
as you know the future looks different
today there we go so good afternoon uh
chairman Mills and representatives thank
you for allowing us to speak this
afternoon I want to First address the
change that we have going on and the way
the system has looked at priority
projects both on a campus and within our
campuses across the system and
accelerating hide because it does make
sense to finish the project started as
we continue to evaluate the rest of our
projects on different campuses so for
Keen state we've gone through a very
very robust review of every space on
campus we've gone through a utilization
study we've gone through a master
planning process and we've gone through
a strategic planning process and through
that we want to make sure that we're
leveraging our assets um appropriately
leveraging our funding that we're
getting from the state and as we move
through that um process we realize it it
Elliott was first presented in 2021 but
since then as the campus has changed as
higher ed has changed and we realized
how much it would cost for a building
Elliott is 92,000 Square
ft we still believe it's a priority
project but we weren't able to
effectively leverage the funding that we
would get from the state to make the um
appropriate Renovations and improvements
and deferred maintenance um changes that
we needed with that funding so we looked
at other high priority projects and
those are the ones were Shifting the
funding too and deferring what we need
to do on Elliott it's a massive project
and we felt like we would better utilize
and leverage the funds from the state
the funds that we had from our education
and general funds to be able to complete
projects that most impact our students
and those using our
campus so I'll start with that um and
I'll certainly take questions afterwards
as I get through the
presentation red for an art center is
slide
16 it's an 81,000 squ ft building that
was originally constructed in 1981 it
has three section main sections to it it
has a main theater of 600 seats alumni
Recital Hall of
370 and putam arts lecture hall of 100
so you can understand the flexibility it
is the most equipped venue in the madn
region our corner of the state there um
this does provide
um both uh uh it's a home for our
theater and dance Department our music
department our all Steinway program that
um we recently commit completed and it's
academic and community so bringing those
two together as we are a big part of the
of the madok region and the Keen
Community but first and foremost is
supporting those students um getting
degrees in those areas as well as other
students taking classes and
participating in those programs
um we've committed our own funds at the
same time that we're requesting funds
from the state um recently we've done
all of the life safety deferred
maintenance of over $5 million to
upgrade that building envelope signage
improvements um fire systems and so
forth um you can see the list of items
that we've we've already done so we're
asking for respectfully asking for
another million dollars to continue
investing in it this year we're
investing out of our own funds
$800,000 um to comp to replace the
failed HVAC unit um and what we're
asking for are um and we've continued to
do some roofing repair we need another
700,000 for roofing that needs
replacement and 300,000 for replacement
of those failed original wood windows
which would give us better Energy
Efficiency but also failing Windows
where we have a failed HV AC system are
us that's a million dooll investment if
we look at slide
17 I'll move on to Morrison Hall which
is our primary investment Morrison Hall
is one of our primary if not the primary
academic building two floors of
classrooms some faculty office and the
majors that we're talking about are
history modern languages psychology
journalism um and other arts and
humanities those are just the majors
because keeping in mind that students
that aren't Majors that are in our stem
programs still take those liberal arts
classes so really touches just about
every student on campus uses that
building it was named after Henry
Morrison and he was a key figure in the
founding of keen normal school back in
1909 um the building was constructed in
1961 we've done what we can to focus on
key deferred maintenance over the years
but certainly nothing substantive has
been done which is why you know we've
done um some updates LED fixtures take
advantage of some energy efficiencies uh
section of the roof new fire panel that
was required for Life Safety but right
now A fullscale renovation is needed for
our students current and future to be
able to use this space so um we're
asking for $5
million this is life safety Ada and
critical deferred
maintenance our bathrooms are not ADA
Compliant they are completely outdated
um we don't have a central HVAC system
which provides challenges in in the
learning environment for our students um
an entrance Portico is deteriorating to
the point where it's not safe and will
continue to be even more unsafe unless
we address that as well as Tower the
stairs and the hallway tile flooring
that's popping up so
um all of that with deferred maintenance
being eliminated as part of the
renovation um totals $5
million our last space that we
would respectfully request funding
for is for our Ketty house it's a stick
frame building a wood frame excuse me uh
we've done some minor r to that and
right now it primarily um our campus
safety uh office uses most of the space
we also have a second floor where we
have some office space for faculty in
our nursing and dietetic um Majors um
this is uh critical life safety
requirements and deferred maintenance
related to the slate roof and windows
we've just recently had a life safety
review by our State Fire Marshall and
this is in direct response to those
items that were noted as um clear
improvements that needed to be made for
it to be used as we um as we use it
today um all of the exterior windows
need replacement framing sheet rock
slate roof and sprinkler work utility
relocation and sheetrock
replacement those are the um
improvements that would go towards the
$1
million I believe that uh wraps up the
presentation for Keen State I'd welcome
any questions that you might
have any questions representative Brown
has your previous question been suitably
answered how it goes how how they go
around representative
Boyd thank you Mr chairman thank you for
your testimony I appreciate it my niece
just graduated from there
so thank you appreciate it she um she's
a very happy owl I will say that very
happy absolutely is she working in New
Hampshire uh my niece is currently back
home in Danvers Massachusetts with my
sister and brother-in-law and she is
working two jobs but predominantly she
is back working for the town of Danvers
uh her Focus was on psychology and a
specific minor that I'm drawing a blank
on but she's working in there after
after Care Program kids get out of
school they go there um until their
parents get out of work and pick them up
so she's trying to figure out what the
what the next steps are going to be so
uh I I appreciate the interest but she
had an amazing four years and um she's
got a guy friend and several good
girlfriends and um she she she bemon
missing chak cuder night every Thursday
so so I think that's a good thing so uh
I have a couple questions um you alluded
to in your testimony that you're
pivoting from Elliot to go to Redfern
and and Cy what remains to be done at
Elliot and what's the what's the price
tag on
that Elliot would be about a $20 million
price tag if you'll recall the history
behind Elliott and and I should have
started out with that Elliott the main
historical building was the old Elliott
hospital for Keen um if anybody can we
actually have people on campus that were
born at Elliott hospital so it's an so
we do have um Elliot the main section is
the historical mansion and then there
have been add-ons they have added on and
added on and added on the space is um
not conducive to all of the student
services that we have in there um the
the same reasons we originally asked for
it still stand with the Departments that
are in Elliott the admissions student
advisory services financial aid student
accounts um our Counseling Center all of
that is still in Elliott it's just that
the money we have available to us in our
unrestricted funds are not sufficient
along with the state funding to make the
kind of impact we would need right now
we're just asking for a couple more
years before we can come back with
hopefully more funding that we have
available along with State funding to be
able to do that but with the amount of
funding that we're asking for we think
there will be a bigger impact on our
students in our campus by um pivoting to
what we've seen from our utilization and
master planning pivoting to what we can
actually complete with that funding with
Morrison kedy um uh and uh Redfern
follow follow up thank you thank you for
the question I appreciate the followup
uh pivoting to the $800,000 investment
on the
HVAC yes I'm I'm happy that you have
skin in the game I just my question is
um what what revenues are you pulling
from to to to pay for that unit is it a
combination of of gift um no that one is
out of our um unrestricted funds or e e
education in general coming from normal
tuition and other Revenue Kathy did
you I don't know if this is helpful at
all when I when I mentioned the capital
budget annually of the University system
the way our capital budget is built is
we target one times depreciation right
so we have G uh financial statements on
based on generally accepted accounting
principles and depreciation is an
expense a non-cash expense but the whole
theory behind depreciation is you're
going to plow it back into your Capital
so so we target one times depreciation
so when you ask about the
800,000 that would be funded from Keen
one time depreciation when it's putting
its capital budget together that's
approved each year by our Board of
Trustees if that's helpful no that makes
sense and I get that I get that follow
you as it relates to Morrison Hall only
because I have a as as Miss preventure
can relate to to the challenge that we
have regarding a school administrative
unit in in our community how long has
Morrison Hall been non-ada compliant is
exposure they are non ADA Compliant if
we in order for us to do any Renovations
or any deferred maintenance work we have
to address the Ada needs so when we
built the building nothing's changed
saying we're out of compliance because
we built according to the laws and
regulations in place at that time once
we start doing any of this type of
renovation work and deferred maintenance
then we have to adhere to the ADA
requirements okay um and it's the it's
the right thing to do as we're
continuing through addressing the
Deferred maintenance and Renovations no
I agree with you I agree with you on
that and one one last question Mr
chairman one last question thank you I
apologize I'm going to withdraw my
question Mr chairman thank you we'll
we'll see if we come back to you
representative jurus thank you Mr
chairman for the for the HVAC
improvements have you considered um on
these two halls have you considered uh
heat pumps at all and and for the
roofing have you considered
photovoltaics
or I'm sorry portable heat pumps for the
uh the H system a a steam you have Steam
Plant okay that we use throughout our
campus um so really the HVAC is just um
air circulation and thank you and that
sure representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman so when you were talking about
the Elliott my concern was you're you're
putting the money to good use now in the
existing buildings I'm s Safi what you
were saying that but then as you were
talking about the LA my concern is just
like a lot of the budgets that we're
reviewing you're deferring and now
you're saying when you do the repairs
it's going to be $20 million that's a
pretty big chunk of change and then I'm
concerned that because we're deferring
this that this facility uh will
deteriorate further as opposed to maybe
spending some money more wisely now to
take harison listening I just want to
make sure that that's addressed in your
future plans thank you C certainly if I
may answer um and thank you for that
question because we continue and we have
a very good track record of making sure
that we take care of those critical
deferred maintenance needs although they
may be peac meal so we do have some um
Elliot improvements and deferred
maintenance being done it's just that we
don't have the funding to do everything
at once within the banum so we won't
spend 20 million on it now but that
price change has only changed because of
cost increases not because of additional
deferred maintenance or the the
significant portion of what's that price
tag is not the price increases or
additional deferred maintenance each
year it's just about the same because we
continue to try and keep up with it
peace meal and that goes throughout
campus thank you representative Jack do
you have do you have anything
representative
Jack the the prior six-year plan is now
fully executed there's nothing there's
no funds going in between these
BS that's correct representative thank
you for your question the the six-year
banial plan is spent we have some
probably some small things to spend left
well from now until the end of the year
on Hyde um it does remind me though um
the Spalding Life Sciences Center at the
University of New Hampshire $95 million
project really brings the
university um into a different place
with life sciences and New Hampshire
Life Sciences has been identified by the
B business and economic Affairs
Department as one of the fastest growing
areas so really I think big impact for
our state and our Workforce um because
the state that was a $95 million project
the state partnered for $35 million over
the past six years so significant amount
and the university invested 60 million
there will be a grand opening in June I
I would love to send the committee if
you're interested and available if you
have any interest in in seeing um a
project that the state really had huge
impact on that I think will drive
Workforce we we'd be happy to come to a
$35 million party terrific well I'm not
saying the part's going to be it'll 35
million there'll be a party if we show
up and and Hyde Hall at Plymouth the
same thing I think that will also
there'll be a grand opening there and
that the state has invested significant
along with the university to to Really
Drive some impact for our future so the
last question for them is from
representative Newman yes um Chancellor
you had said at the beginning that
enrollment was down at UNH is enrollment
down also at Kean and at Plymouth so so
enrollment is declining frankly
enrollment is declining at almost all
institutions of Higher Learning unless
you're you know maybe Harvard uh because
of the demographic headwinds in New
England there are just
fewer high school graduates and you know
that I'm sure from the towns that you
live in um and so that enrollment
decline puts a lot of competitive
pressure on institutions of higher ed in
New England there's like one on every
street corner here in New England and so
again that it's it's going to continue
and we're planning for it and it's it's
painful we have to reimagine
what we're going to look like and um so
enrollment has been declining across the
university system some campuses have a
you know bigger like UNH was flat this
year Plymouth was down this year so but
overall if you look over the past five
years enrollments declined about 11%
undergrad um non-res and res actually
tidbit and then I'll let you go um this
fall was the first time since
2013 we had more New Hampshire students
entering us as um as freshmen and um I
contribute that in part we've we've the
university system has received
increasing operating support from the
state we've held tuition flat New
Hampshire tuition flat for the past six
years and and I think that had an impact
on and we know our new New Hampshire
students are more likely to stay and
work here so we we we have to all drive
to to keep more of our New Hampshire
students here in the state so Chancellor
thank you very much for your
presentation thank you thank you very
much and contact information is on the
last page of your deck so if you have a
question that comes up later by all
means we're we're always happy to to get
answers to your questions thanks so much
representative
more well I mean if you have to go you
go then go by just let me know ahead of
good afternoon welcome to Public Works
PE development Port Authority um and
we'll do it in your order because I
think we can get rid of the first couple
of pages rather quick you started with
lapse extensions yes and for the record
I'm Paul Breen I'm the executive
director of Peace Development Authority
uh airport sponsor of Portsmith
International Airport Sky Haven airport
in Rochester and also have
administrative oversight of the P of
division of ports and harbors um yes to
to be brief uh we do have one lapse item
essentially that is a project uh
associated with the Turnin Basin
dredging of the piscatqua bay um some of
you may recall that we dredged that so
that large ships could could turn there
is one Boulder remaining um Army Corps
of Engineers uh they hope to address it
uh potentially through another project
at at at division of Porton harbors
where they can mobilize the specific
equipment needed for that large Boulder
removal um so that's the only lapse for
you uh we do have three projects that
are closing out uh the main paay
Rehabilitation that's the major
restoration over the Market Street deep
water birth um we're basically on our
button list uh punch list items for that
project and we hope to have that
completed by one essentially the last
part is applying epoxy um uh sail coat
on on the decking um the second one is
the commercial Portsmouth commercial
fish pair uh decking and bracing project
this was to restore the wooden Paar that
offloads the commercial um uh catch the
commercial fish catch and allows the the
fishermen to get to their vessels um and
we we believe that should be buttoned up
uh early this spring
and um very small amount to be paid out
[Music]
ready and operational by uh the end of
the spring we're trying to meet the
needs of the commercial fishing fleet
and and get putting a good turn on
restoring that building to operation um
but essentially we have uh
$776,000
outstanding and uh division of Porton
Harbors has
$225,000 internally outstanding on that
um and as I explained we do have the one
lapse item for the boulder
removal and finally uh we have three
projects before you put in Porton
Harbors um the first one wait second
sorry
representative representative Jack are
you good with all the laps extensions
then proceed please thank you thank you
Mr chair I apologize uh Market Street
Marine Terminal main Warf dredging uh 1
point just over $1.4 million essentially
this request is is to uh dredge along
the the Deep birth terminal uh just to
give you an idea we currently have
sediment and debris uh along the war
and this would ultimately allow a
contractor to come in and remove that
and allow uh larger draft vessels to
utilize the port to to to give you an
idea currently if we have a a a road
salt shipment coming in from from uh
Chile uh they may have to stop at a port
in New York or or Chelsea Massachusetts
to actually offload tonnage um so that
they can get their draft a little bit a
little bit uh higher because of the the
sediment and debris that's along our
Warf um so this would Bode very well
with the business that we're trying to
win with the new new re reinstated uh
main Warf and this would just allow us
to get uh deeper deeper sh birth ships
and more warpage to be offloaded at the
facility the second item is the Ry
Harbor and hampon harbor rip wrap repair
um we've had we're we're what we call at
the uh tip of the spear for uh sea level
rising um and Ry Harbor and hon Harbor
are two facilities that are seeing uh
that most directly in 2018 we have
significant storm storage that caused a
tremendous amount of damage at Ry and
Hampton um that was uh we saw additional
king tide Storm surges in
2023 uh two events that primarily uh
created a substantial amount of damage
um from the 2018 storm FEMA did come and
give us an assessment and gave us uh
design plans to actually strengthened
the rip wrap um revetment at Ry Harbor
and and gave us um ideas and initiatives
how to strengthen Hampton Harbor um that
valuation in today's number is now at
$765,000 um but that would be to
directly improve the revetment and rip
wrap uh basically the seaw wall at the
harbor and and allow us to um support
maintaining our infrastructure uh as a
sustainable initiative uh long term
and then finally um this one continues
to become more of a priority but we we
do think the other two projects are more
significant at this time but our Market
Street Marine Terminal Warehouse uh also
houses the the offices for division and
ports and harbors and to give you a
little history lesson many of you
probably aware but the the the warehouse
there it's about a 177,000 foot
Warehouse um it was built in the 1970s
and the idea was that New Hampshire
liquor sales the liquor would come in uh
via vessel and be stored on site um that
practice hasn't been in place in decades
uh The Liquor Commission has a logistics
company that that handles it very
efficiently um and there is no liquor
stored at the warehouse we have used the
warehouse for different OD ad hoc type
movements but it's really underutilized
and it's in it's in poor uh uh state of
state of repair um essentially we
actually have a moratorium right now
that um if we have a a snow load of of
over 10 Ines in in a wind of 30 miles an
hour we actually have to have our
employees work remotely um out of the
building um this last uh this past
winter we did have the the snow load uh
fortunately before um this week's high
winds we we did get a snow melt so we
didn't have to have Personnel um not
work in the office but um we see it as
becoming a priority we do believe that
uh the warehouse does not need need to
be re replaced the number that we have
you that one 1.97 is really a design
build for um a professional office
building that supports division in ports
and harbers and some of the entities the
stakeholders that work out of the 55
Market Street Terminal in in in
Portsmouth are there any questions on
the projects
questions representative Brown thank you
Mr chairman so um on your guess third
page pment to commercial fishing perer
building replacement
I was reading that this is uh for lapse
extensions but in the dialogue there it
says that the building sits on
approximately 1.9 Acres above water
location is currently over 50% shutdown
due to the presence of black mold
identified in recent condition survey
the wooden structure has deterior is at
the end of its useful existence and is
need of replacement so is there an
upcoming project for this should I miss
that I'm sorry representative Brown that
that actually building has through the
oper funding project that was about $1
million division of ports Harbor self
funded about 225,000 on that that
building has been demolished um and we
are starting to work on the foundation
and utility work and we hope to have
that building fully operational by June
1 of this year okay so so we don't have
to worry about that I'm sorry the black
mold is gone thank you very much I
Edgar oh thank you Mr chair I had a
couple questions uh one of them I'm
trying to see if I can get a page number
on but
uh this one here anyway I we got do with
some of the Dron showing uh we'll call
it the main pair dredging diagram main
yeah maintenance dredge plan
is is a engineering draw in there um
that shows some along the you know along
the pier itself then there's a uh
another one later on it's got all the
red on it and I'm trying to again page
number I don't have one but it shows a
lot more dring um is this request to do
all the in all that's in red I'm under
the impression that this request is to
do along the warf the red is actually
part of uh what Federal Highway
Department um owes the state of New
Hampshire uh for the for the Sarah Sarah
along Bridge replacement yes sir you I
to follow up on that follow yeah that's
and that's why I was asking so what's
the status of that the status of that is
it's still factored in uh the Do's uh
program and I believe that we just were
received that uh a perming a perming
application is is starting to be
processed that hopefully will kick
through the Army Corp of Engineers that
will hopefully start to kick that
project off
but I'm
sorry hope we out to bid in
May yeah okay that's so that will be
done one more please follow up thank you
okay and um the other one is when you
start talking about work at at Ry in
Hampton Harbor um you look at the
narrative the uh just Agency number you
know
013 talks about rip wrap here but there
also was a problem as it mentions here
with the uh ramps going down in is this
request to also repair the
ramps so the division of ports and
harbor self-funded the immediate repair
of the ramp after the
202 for king tide yeah um this this
project will strengthen the ramp and
hopefully preserve the actual boat
launching um pad that that allows
recreational and Commercial vendors to
to launch their vehicles mo more
importantly it uh it also strengthens
our um infrastructure for our fuel um
tanks in infrastructure there as well
yeah and just just one last one please
please the uh so the ramp is is
completely acceptable now because it
this that ramp's been a problem in
Hampton particular for years so with the
repairs it's actually fully acceptable
now it's represent vard I'm going to
defer to Tom Maciel our operations
manager who's a bit more familiar with
Hampton than I
am again it's Tom Macio operations
manager division ports and
harvers Sir the 2024 storm uh I'm not I
haven't read the paperwork in front of
you but the repairs done at the boat
ramp was in Ry Harbor uh the Hampton
Harbor boat ramp was not damaged from
the store we do recognize it's in a
state of bad repair um but that's not
the item that uh director Breen was
speaking
on I apologize I was thinking of the Rye
boat launch um but we we would be
Associated $73,000 worth of funds at
Hampton through this project to
specifically address some of the issues
there s one more thank you so is there
any plan on actually making the Hampton
ramp to be in better shape it's it's
it's pretty rough right well we what we
have before you is our Capital project
uh state funded um we do continuously
work on our internal funded programs and
that is on our our wish
list thank
questions representative cluder thank
you
and this is about the third page in uh
again I got the mar Street marine
terminal at the very bottom a reduction
in total cost of project isve done in
conjunction with functional replacement
of barge Dock and it would be reduced
according to this information
$250,000 a quarter of a million but
something about that project is 100%
federally funded would there be any
state cost if you decide to include it
in capital budget but yet and and you
know if we did this all at once yeah
yeah so we're recognizing from our
professional Engineering Services in the
Army Corp of Engineers that there would
be a savings of
$250,000 if it coincided with uh the
main Warf uh dredge okay follow up I
want something about 100% federally
funded would there be any money the
state would have to put up for this
functional replacement of the bar St no
sir there's not there's no State share
it's owed to us from the Federal Highway
project it would be
allal correct
corre Mr Shay would we need any uh more
that provided to us
by I I would just want to talk with them
offline just to make sure I've got
everything understand it all okay pleas
follow up on that and get back to us on
Tuesday y representative
kazinski thank you um that we house
there's a am I correct there's like 20
people working in there now uh I would
reduce that to about six yeah six full
full-time employees and then we do have
uh uh part-time employees report
reporting muster there followup yeah and
uh so you're looking to replace it with
the with the uh with an office building
correct uh unfortunately the way that it
was designed the the original Warehouse
was built in the 1970s I believe the
office building was was constructed our
cinder block in 2005 as part of the into
part of the warehouse we're being told
by our architectural firms that you
cannot take down the warehouse without
sacrificing the Integrity of the
existing office building so it would be
a demolition of the warehouse which is
factored into the cost estimate and then
a construction of a new specific office
building to support division in Porton
Harbors so what's that like a two
twostory building or something um we we
actually have some conceptuals based on
on on from other buildings that we've
seen But essentially uh about a one
about a two-story height building one
that is you know about six offices a
conference room and file storage and
some some Workshop area for the harbor
Masters and other people to be able to
work and a kitchen any further
questions see none thank you very much
for your presentation to thank you Mr
chairman and I will say I I was here for
the dot at 1:30 and I I I I hung in the
room and I will say I have a new found
appreciation for the committee work that
you all do so thank you well we have a
we have a Governor's budget of 143
million and I think we have requests for
my running total is about 170 right now
so understood our our our tough work's
coming thank you for your time couple of
just as far as official business for
this committee goes um Friday will be
the lapse extension meeting if you have
been named as a member of that committee
you know it
anybody else is welcome to come and
attend and see how that the intricacies
of how that works um I might even stop
in aside from that next Tuesday at 10:
I'm sorry yeah next Tuesday at 10 we'll
have the uh public hearing and at 10:30
we're going to start uh whittling that
150 or 60 million that they want down to
a reasonable amount
Mr Shay Mr chair just to follow up on
the P's and the um project that repon
cluder was asking about so the Market
Street U Marine Terminal main Warf
dredging has already deducted that
$250,000 so you'll see that um if you
were to flip there's a page with a
spreadsheet on it and there's some ink
writing it looks like ink
writing I don't have a page
number actually on the bottom of it it
says page one of one one that says so if
you go to page one of one yeah it's from
it's from Andover Apple door Marine
yes you'll see that the The Authority
had already taken the deduction of that
$250,000 from the project so there would
be no change needed then we no longer
need any further
verbage so anyway that's where we're at
see some of you on Friday the rest of
you on
Monday who
Tuesday I'm sorry
Tuesday bring bring your ideas yes Mr
representa CL how long do you think the
meeting on Friday will be just in case I
want to attend I'm not sure yet at this
point I have we have input from every
agency with well with one exception who
was supposed to get back to us and is
not and we're going to hammer on them so
I would expect it to be just a review of
all the information that we have and
everyone nods so
it could be over in an hour hour okay
all right thank you representative
Jack um all right so again Mr CH now
question to you we will meet on Tuesday
and that start at 10: a.m. there'll be a
formal public hearing on House Bill 25
is that correct correct okay all right
great and then we'll get into a work
session now we're going to go right into
a work session okay thank you Public
Works our public should be less than a
half